Queen yourself, Kelly Jean, the the Alog
community that has spent a substantive
amount of time kind of, you know,
documenting his behavior recently and in
the past. How could I not just use this
to like go after anybody? This is
broadly how, you know, Keeles blamed him
for his community hate rating him and
stuff, right? It was just like, oh,
based on some vague illusion to a
connection, I'm going to go ahead and
say that like whatever we do against you
is justified. I can go and report your
YouTube, your Twitch, whatever. Now it's
all justified. So I would say this is
very much, hey, you have to stop what
you're doing and I will dox you and
terrorize you and I'm justified in doing
that because you have talked about me. I
don't know. It's just like it's one of
those things where it's like, okay,
doxing is pretty bad. Okay, like calling
for my death and the death of other
people you've attempted to do, that's
also pretty bad. Putting those things
together, I don't really know how you
get um I felt like more people would
kind of be outraged about that to tell
you the truth. It's a little offensive.
How's life? Oh, pretty good. How are
you? uh been better to tell you the
truth, been a little less uh I had
fewer, you know, calls for my death, you
know, at previous points in my life. So,
been interesting. How's the uh how's the
doxing reverse docs? How's that thing
going? Uh I don't know. I guess it's
we'll see if like anything happens. I
don't know. It's just like it's one of
those things where it's like, okay,
doxing's pretty bad. Okay. Like calling
for my death and the death of other
people you've attempted to dox. That's
also pretty bad. Putting those things
together. I don't really know how you
get um I felt like more people would
kind of be outraged about that to tell
you the truth. It's a little offensive.
Well, how many uh just out of curiosity,
how many death threats have you gotten?
Me personally, oh, lots of people have
done it like through um Twitter DMs or
Discord or chat or whatever. But it's
like um it's not it's like under it's
like the I don't take it seriously when
it's like just anonymous accounts like
clearly trying to with you. You know
what I'm saying? Like if you made that
account yesterday and you type a message
about like my docs being up somewhere,
I'm just like, "Okay, I don't take you
seriously." What? Uh I haven't had like
a lot of credible death threats other
than from Destiny. How did you feel
about um his response where he was
saying, you know, ba basically like,
"Oh, yeah. Uh Jtock, well, I mean, I
don't think he said names, but you know,
he said Jively what I took away from it
was Jtock and Queen play footsie with
Kiwi Farm. So it it's cute that they're
pretending that they give a [__] about
this when their parts of their
communities are schizophrenic docs or
Yeah. I would just wonder like so he
blamed me for getting swatted. I don't
know when he was swatted, but I know at
least one of them was from the
Republican the Trump thing, right? So
like I couldn't have possibly been
responsible for that. Um I think the
other one was the Muslim thing, but I'm
not 100% sure. So to me, I would wonder
why he would bring up doxing or sorry
swatting when that has like very little
to do with me. I think broadly I would
ask, you know, if I if I could have
asked him a question there in the
moment, I would have just said, "Okay,
could you like walk me through your
evidence?"
Oh, one second. Hold on. Confirmation
bias donated J SDLK. Can you try to put
him on Bill Maher's shoulders? Sure. I
can try to put him on Bill Maher's
shoulders. I'm putting your head on Bill
Mar's shoulders on my stream. So I would
just say like could you connect some of
those dots for me because it seems like
overall like how could I not just use
this to like go after anybody? This is
broadly how you know Keels blamed him
for his community hate rating him and
stuff, right? It was just like oh based
on some vague illusion to a connection
I'm going to go ahead and say that like
whatever we do against you is justified.
I can go and report your YouTube, your
Twitch, whatever now it's all justified,
right? And he was pretty vehement about
arguing against that. that like without
solid links and without letting the
other person know. Like for example, he
said, "Oh, there's like a ton of he does
this all the time and it's just a
malicious lie, right? Where he'll say,
"Oh, Jtock has like people who link my
revenge on his discord server or
something like that." No revenge has
ever been linked to my server. Uh the
Kiwi Farms links are blocked or uh
deleted like there and you get timed out
for referencing KF stuff. So like I just
don't understand broadly how he is um
how he makes that claim. Like I guess
that rule came in somewhere somewhere in
the middle and like it is mods do have
to actively like do something. Uh he
also yeah claimed I actively
collaborated with them or but then again
I would just want the proof that he has
that shows the links because like can I
do you think I could sufficiently be
blamed or held responsible or have
people like actually try to attack or
give consequences to me for things that
are like six degrees removed from me?
Like if it's if it's somebody who like
I've once messaged in my Discord who has
once messaged somebody from Kiwi Farms
who was once posted in the thread who
was once like maybe posted a reply to
somebody who's docked someone. I like I
don't know can I be what do you think
about that connection? Because it seemed
like you were pretty willing to just
take that qu that answer and I was like
oh I really wish you asked for
something. I think when you're having
these conversations right like I I I
think when you're having these
conversations Sorry what's that? Can you
hear me? Okay. Sorry, I I was just
saying it's tough in the m moment. I was
agreeing with you. Okay. Yeah. So, the
Well, it's it's not just tough tough in
the moment. It's it's a question of, you
know, what what are you trying to
achieve, right? So, for me, uh that this
conversation was kind of at least the
way that I pitched it to him and the way
that I wanted the conversation to go
was, uh I'm I'm kind of interrogating
his, you know, moral philosophy, the way
he perceives the way that he was acting
in 2022 and the way that he's acting
now. If if I had to be uh honest, then I
would say the I was kind of disappointed
that there wasn't an articulation of a
change, right? It was kind of like,
well, back then, I don't even know if he
said this. This this might be me
inferring something that he might not
have even said, uh, but he said that
like, well, at the time, I acted based
off of my moral system then, so there's
no way that I could have like foreseen
the consequences of my behavior. um
therefore I wouldn't change anything.
Whereas now, uh this is me reading into
it. Uh I I would try to balance my
pleasure- seeeking behavior more with my
like moral obligations. But that's of
course like a very non-specific answer,
right? like that that doesn't really
that doesn't really tell me like what
are you copying to that you actuallyed
up on versus what did you change about
your perceptions around and pleasure
seeking and relationships that's going
to prevent this kind of [__] happening
from the future. Sure. And I don't know
if you I don't know if you put it quite
that way. I think that could have been a
good way maybe maybe it didn't I just
missed it of like I would expect this to
happen again unless you have changed
something philosophically. Right. Yeah.
and and and I I don't think you know I
don't think in the conversation I I like
pressed him to be like no you must you
must tell me what you have changed tell
me what you have changed now like that
obviously didn't happen um but you know
that that that's also kind of the a a
non-answer is also an answer right so if
he's if he's avoiding specifically
saying what he's changed then he might
not have interrogated his moral system
that much since this incident which
would be uh you you know, problematic
because that would basically mean that
there isn't much preventing it from
happening in the future. Sure. So, I
guess there's probably two different
directions we could go with like this
conversation. Um, I would wonder I guess
I to me I'm kind of wondering why the
2025 behavior wouldn't be more
concerning to you than it seems to be
cuz I think that is like actually just
sort of like calculated over time. Hey,
I'm I'm saying I'm like asking for these
guys' docs and then I'm trying to
publish docs that I'm saying are them
like a month later. Like it seems like
that's like he announces he wants them
and to publish them to harass these
people and then he publishes the docs
like 3 weeks or a month later that he
purports to be the docs and then he goes
on to call for the death of these people
and then he goes on to justify multiple
times on his YouTube channel calling for
the death of these people myself and
Queen specifically. Yeah, I I have to I
have to think about what what I believe
is sincere versus what I believe is an
excuse, I guess. And and what I mean by
that, so uh if I can articulate Steven's
arguments as best I can, and you can
correct me if you heard something
different. So Ste Steven's argument, and
and I I'm not saying it's correct. I'm
saying what he said uh is that uh Queman
and yourself I'm just going to use names
because I'm presuming you know that he's
talking about Queen and yourself. Um
Queen yourself, Kelly Jean, the the Alog
community that has spent a substantive
amount of time kind of, you know,
documenting his behavior recently and in
the past, uh that they play fast and
loose and cutesy with more nefarious
organizations. when he's talking about
more nefarious organizations, I'm ass
I'm straight up assuming that he's
talking about like Kiwi Farms and Doc
and that when you're, you know, when
when we're having this conversation now
where you're like, well, what did I
specifically do? In my opinion, he's
saying that you're like playing koi and
cute because your your connections with
these communities are more strong than
you're letting on. I I don't know the
truth of that now. I I don't even know
if I care to interrogate it. It wouldn't
that be like absolutely wouldn't that be
the most important thing to interrogate?
Why? Because it's what it's all
predicated on. Um like literally he's
giving you an excuse that he can provide
no evidence for and I would just be
hesitant to take somebody's word for
something when they have just
maliciously lied against like about a
bunch of people involved in these
scenarios. Right. Yeah. But I don't
know. Can I just give you example? Like
you work for PV. You saw him publish
that Wicked Supreme had an illicit
relationship with Pixie when he was her
supervisor at PV, right? Yeah. So, like
I probably if somebody just is
maliciously in this scenario, I feel
like I would have in my opinion I don't
know how that relationship would be
elicit. Uh that it would have been a I
guess an age gap of some kind and then a
supervisor and a an employee. He was
trying to imply that it was weird that
like Supreme was way older, way more
power scenario. Just being real. Um
because I was saying earlier like we
have to interrogate, you know, what's
real versus what's not. I don't believe
him that he's upset about that. I I I
think that what happened was I I I think
what happened was Wicked Supreme was
talking he wanted something to throw
back at him and then he just picked the
closest thing that he could to some kind
of you know some kind of uh what what do
you what do you call it? Impugn like
where you impug somebody's character. Uh
he he tried to find the closest thing
that he could in order to impugn Wicked
Supreme's character. He just threw it at
the wall even though I very much doubt
he cared about it at all. So, in order
to get back at Wicked Supreme, he made
up a malicious lie about him to try to
malign him to his community. And I'm
just curious why not what what what part
of it is a lie? Um, I think that they
dated while Peavey was going on. I think
that he's that much older than her. I
think that he was ever her supervisor. I
think every element of the thing he said
was a malicious lie that Arodite and the
leader of Pavey both corroborated and
said was a clear malicious lie. What?
What do you mean the leader of Pave and
Kyla corroborated that it was a lie? Uh
Kyla posted on Twitter, "This is
obviously a lie. This is obviously not
true." And then somebody who was high up
in PV, I can't remember if it was um I
can't remember if it was Sam or not.
Somebody I I don't think it was Sam, I
think it was somebody else, corroborated
that. Yeah, this is just a lie. This is
like not true. He was not her
supervisor. Um yeah, so every single
element except the fact that they had a
relationship in the past was a malicious
lie. Well, yeah. Yeah. Yeah. So, so I
don't I I don't want to legal ease it.
Um, and by legal it I just mean like uh
I the the thing that he's trying to
point to, you know, in my opinion. Well,
well, hold on. Let's see if we can skip
ahead to like the solution. We can both
agree that he probably doesn't care
about a fratern like a what do you call
that? Like a conflict of interest
relationship. He probably doesn't care
about that. He probably doesn't care
about the age gap. He probably doesn't
care about whether or not he was a
supervisor. Right. It all all that was
happening was one of his friends was
talking or one of his former friends was
talking about him. He felt hurt and he
was lashing out, right? Yeah. The
talking [__] by the way, was saying
like, "Oh, I used to watch Bill Cosby,
then I watched Louis CK, and then I
found Destiny. What am I doing to these
people?" That's like the talking [__]
that he decided to make this malicious
layup that involved one of his victims.
Okay. One of the people he I guess so
again, like that's kind of the thing
where Well, actually, this is kind of
what I was going to get at is um I don't
know if you're expecting me to like
defend him. I I I don't I don't think I
will be defending him. I I think I'll
just be, you know, kind of like uh
articulating what I understand under the
situation as best I can. Sure. So, I
guess what I would expect is probably
some demonstration or basically just
saying that you have figured out that
you actually don't hold the values you
previously stated. So, previously you'd
said you totally distance yourself from
somebody who had done doxing or anything
like adjacent to doxing because that's
like probably the worst thing you can
do, right? And that Mr.
convo that happened I think 2 or 3 years
ago and then I think you said in a
conversation with Lav and Queen around
the time this started that you would
need to see contrition on Destiny's part
before collaborating with him again. I
would wonder where the contrition is
that you wanted to see or that you
needed to see and that I would wonder
basically um why when you said doxing
was like that bad before we're like
basically saying okay well he can't
really prove this and he has maliciously
lied about a bunch of people to try to
harm them um that now we're like well we
don't really need to interrogate the the
reasoning for why he's doxing and
calling for the death of people. Um, so
yeah. So hold on. Uh, if I if I'm trying
to summarize, it's like, am I either a
hypocrite or a liar for saying doxing is
one of the worst things you can do? Not
hypocrite. Change your mind. I I don't
need a hypocrite.
Uh, okay. Well, hold on. There was the
doxing and then what was the second one?
Uh, saying, "I hope somebody these
people." Um, what? Death threats. Yeah.
Then he Well, I guess you call him death
threats. I try to be more specific
because if I ever get like one iota off,
he'll try to use that as like a meme
lying about him or something. So, yeah,
sure. Um, so, uh, I I'm going to go I'm
going to go back in history to the best
of my knowledge. Okay. Um, so do I do I
think was brought up in the in the
context of like, uh, etiquette and what
was going on at the time was, and I I
might still feel this way. We'll kind of
interrogate this in a second, like I'm
I'm thinking out loud basically. So, the
reason why I said doxing is one of the
worst things you can do as a creator is
because I do think it's one of the worst
things that you can do. Like, barring
like murder and right. And the reason
why I think I articulated in that
conversation yesterday is because we're
all creators. We're all trying to make
money. We're all trying to gain an
influence and and an audience. And so,
when you dock someone, effectively what
you're saying is, I don't give a if
people are coming after you in a
schizophrenic way in order to try to
hurt you. I don't care if people harass
you. And I don't care if um I'm trying
to think of what else, but that's like
the main thing, right? Like you're
trying to put somebody in fear for their
safety because you think they're such a
piece of And so normally that's outside
of the rules of engagement of the online
discourse. Specifically, what was going
on at the time, even if it's not
relevant, was I was contacted by several
people uh in reference to Kevin Cassley.
I don't know if you remember him, but
Kevin Cassley had allegedly doxed a few
people and people were saying like,
"Stay away." And I I kind of had agreed
at the time because I was like, "Yeah,
that's pretty up." Okay. Um I still
think it's pretty up and and I I guess
that the question or not the question,
but the statement is right now I have,
you know, Stephen saying, "Yeah, I don't
care if I dox Jtock Queen, Kelly Gene,
and some other people." And then when I
ask him about it, he's basically saying
that you guys are already doing the same
to him. And you're you're saying that's
just not true. Yeah, it's just not true.
He is totally making that up. It is
fabricated whole cloth. Um, and because
it's fabricated whole cloth based on,
and if I'm hearing you correct, you're
also saying that you deny that there's
like a I don't know, a cross-pollination
between the drama community, I guess,
that like Queen and yourself have
cultivated in a way that I would be
responsible for that calls for my
doxing. Um, obviously there could be
people who look at Kiwi farms, but like
I can't possibly be held responsible for
that. If I can be held responsible for
that, Destiny absolutely is a fair
target for all of these things. I think
even you based on your hanging around
with Destiny, being in my Discord, being
in Destiny's Discord, it would all apply
to you, too. Like, basically, this is a
this is a free it's it's all it's all
it's a fire sale. Everybody Everybody
can be doxed and and uh apparently,
which is pretty insane. It's not a world
I want to live in, but yeah.
Um I'm trying to think of how I feel
about that. And and so the the reason
why I'm taking a second to kind of think
about it and feel about it is because on
one hand I I I do believe you in the
sense that you're not doing anything
particularly egregious compared to the
rest of the space and therefore it's
kind of crazy to presume that like you
should suffer any like additional you
know additional harm compared to what
you normally do. Um, as far as I can
see, like 90% of your activities are,
you know, effectively I I I hate to use
this term perhaps incorrectly, uh, but
basically like a logging like like you
basically just you just document um,
Steven's bad behavior and then hope that
he crashes out so it gives you more
content. So before I before I guess like
Kelly Jean started talking about his
girlfriend or something in my Discord, I
had mostly moved on. And I would say
about 80% of my time was on different
stuff like non-destiny related. And then
since then, Jesus, since then, I've
basically just had like a whole bunch of
like it's basically been him talking
about it or other people talking about
it and like talking about this general
thing and he's just kept escalating,
right? So it has gone back more to
Destiny, but that's just based on his
actions. Like if I if literally if he
was if he had moved on, like I wouldn't
be covering his stuff. I would rather
cover other things, right? But
unfortunately for me, it's just like
this is good money. This is what people
pay me for. So, in your opinion, just
out of curiosity, what like re-triggered
him? It was probably Kelly talking about
his girlfriend, wasn't wasn't just out
of just out of curiosity, wasn't that
like a month ago as well? Yeah, it was
somewhere around this time. Maybe it was
a couple weeks ago. I'm not totally
sure, but like I had I had largely like
I wasn't covering it very much. I I'd
like moved on until he started like
literally targeting my Discord and
saying that like this was a place where
revenge forms was getting posted or docs
were getting posted, which are both just
totally made up like whole cloth. Yeah.
So, so, so let me tell you my aversion
to being like Destiny is a
monoomaniacal deviant doxer murderer
who's I don't need the hyperbole added,
right? I just like I think you could
just say like he's doxing people and
trying to get them with like or like I
calling for their death with no evidence
for the reasons that he's doing it. But
here's I I don't I don't really want to
agree to that because the the thing
about it is like calling for their
death. Do do we take like uh for for
instance like when
uh Xanderhal was losing his and he was
like I want to I want to Keles what's
her address? I wouldn't even shoot her.
I would beat her with a gun. Are we
taking that like we're not taking that
one seriously? Right. Did Xanderhal go
to multiple YouTube streams after that
and justify those statements and say
that they were actually good and he was
right in doing it? No, I don't I don't
think he necessarily formally apologized
either, but yeah. So, like I'm totally
fine with people like crashing out, but
the repeated justifications are the
concern. Continuing it afterwards. So,
in your in your opinion, um has he
continued this like recently or
afterwards or was it just in the wake of
just
Sorry. Sorry. I'm saying he's justifying
the death threats and the doxing. He
justified it to you. He justified it
like on to his stream like the day
before. Right. So he's not saying, "Oh,
no. I just kind of got heated for a
second." He's saying, "No, no, no. Like
I the these people like dox me." Right.
Right. And there's no proof of the
reason. I'm not saying it's accur his
argument. I'm not saying it's accurate.
I think I need time to think about it.
Um he's saying that like this is
reciprocal because you and Quean are
doing the same thing effectively. Yes.
Yeah. So, so I I think I think before
like making a decision on whether or not
uh you know whose team or anybody's team
really um that I'm on uh I I I think I
would need to like know the whether or
not any of that was true. I I think just
factually I think most of the people
that have been doxed around Destiny got
doxed before the stuff was ever leaked.
Like before like January 20th or
whatever when the studios came out,
right? like the the doxing stuff didn't
happen in response to my coverage. Um
that the one thing he talked about was
somebody on Kiwi Farms threatened Tom
Foolery, but it's like I don't know how
I could be held responsible for Tom
Foolery getting threatened. I wouldn't
want anything bad to happen to Tom. I
wouldn't want his docs posted. I
wouldn't want anything like that. Yeah,
I'm being told that the Xander thing was
bringing this up more because it's
funny, but like wasn't there wasn't
there like an entire like arc where you
effectively were called like to like a
pest or a harasser just to get him to
crash out? Uh yeah, but I literally said
that I don't think he's actually done
anything. Like I literally said to him
in the first conversation I ever had
with him and then gave him logs of me
saying like I don't actually think this,
but then he started out about it for
some reason. Uh you know what, man? Like
I I I hate to be so
unsatisfying. Um but but I I I think I I
would either need to actually like try
to evaluate the validity of Destiny's
claims in order to see whether or not
like you're you're saying that he's just
like bald-faced lying about this. Um, or
see if there was like some kind of
evidence of like some some people in
like Queenman's server or your server
who are all playing footsy who actually
are actively trying to
uh, you know, Doc's girlfriend and Doc's
family and this that the other like like
or if it's legitimately like you said,
it's all related to the Muslim [__] and
it's all related to the conservative
[__] You have nothing to do with it.
Like I think all like some of it blends
at the edges. I'm not sure when certain
people were doxed or something, but it's
like uh that behavior started way before
I ever started covering. Like he had
this issue where people were around him
were getting doxed way before he
actually talks about it in the thing
with you and he talks about Zoe and
Jacob. They were doxed for being around
him when I was still like friendly with
him when he was still coming on my
stream. This was all something that
happened based on his prior behavior
that he is now loading on to me for I
don't know what reason. Well, correct me
if I'm wrong. Uh, wasn't that narrative
and bear in mind I did not know about
the Zoey situation at all. Wasn't the
narrative around that effectively that
like there was a bunch of people in
Queenman and or your chats who were
harassing them for being associated with
Steven after it was already revealed
that he was a bad guy, quote unquote.
And then uh basically they became like I
don't know like you know
minor celebrated figures within the
discords once they said like oh yeah
Steven's like an evil guy and he can eat
a piece of and we hope he dies. Oh that
they what happened. So what he's
referring to okay what he's again I also
need like names but there's one specific
situation he's referring to where the
person who docks them they're like yeah
we don't care about that guy. And that
guy was like oh yeah I don't care about
them anymore. you're a piece of but like
it it yeah they I think they said like
we're good with him or something only
now like the person that docked them and
the people that were getting docked. I
think it was basically like oh uh I like
what happened was Zoe came back to the
Discord. He also made this up entirely.
Uh he he's also maliciously lied about
like um Zoe being the person who like
tried to coach Cherry into making her
tweet or something. Like he also just
totally made that up whole cloth. But uh
Zoe came back to the Discord because Zoe
asked when Destiny was sending like
videos videos to her. She said, "Hey,
uh, I only want these if the other
person consents." And then he sent them.
And then she found out that they didn't
consent. Right? That's broadly what
happened. And she was like, "Oh, this
guy's a total piece of and he made me
party." Wait, is that is that is that
her narrative? Or have people seen like
DMs where she's like, "I only want these
if the other people consent." Wait,
people have seen DMs of this? Yes, I
could pull the DMs out for you. They've
seen DMs of her saying, "I only want
these other people consent." Yep. And
what what date what date was this? When
when was this? This would have been uh
probably like uh December 2023 to
February 2024, maybe going back a little
earlier in 2023. Okay, then I'm going to
I'm going to macro macro zoom out. Can
you can you give me a little bit of
latitude real quick? And I'm I'm just
going to explain it from my perspective.
Sure. Um yeah, again, I just want to You
want to keep going into the drama stuff?
We can. I don't care. I I just It's fine
with me. It's just that um I just want
to say that a lot of times you guys like
he'll say there's a bunch of people who
do this. This stuff all happens here and
all I ever want is connect that to me.
Connect that to Queen. Explain why
you're doxing these people. Why wouldn't
you just go and try to like dox I don't
know the the other people. Why are you
doxing? Why are you doxing calling for
my death? And realistically he he always
does this. This is one other thing I
wanted to add. He always does this
really stupid thing where he's like oh
just cuz they're smaller I'm not allowed
to talk about. It's like, no, literally
analyze any one of my VODs, Destiny, on
your stream and point out where I'm
lying. Like, I'm totally fine with that.
I have no issue with him actually
attacking any of the ideas I've said,
any of the things I've said. I don't
have a problem with him attacking them.
But, but like that's not what he does,
right? He doesn't attack them at all. He
doesn't actually engage with anything
I'm saying. He just goes and like doxes
and calls for my death. Very odd. Very
odd for a community that apparently is
all about talking things out. Yeah. So,
so this might go a little bit too wide.
And if you need to reel me back in, you
know, feel feel free to. But I just I
just feel like kind of articulating my
perspective is so so Stephen has
presided over Twitch and YouTube
politics for probably what is 2025 right
now. I don't know like eight or nine
years, right? Like I think I think he
made his political switch in 2016 and
that's when the debate scene was big. I
I came in the debate scene in like 19.
You know, it kind of died out in 22 23
and then, you know, we've all been kind
of living in the in the corpse of Twitch
and YouTube politics for, you know, 2
years now. And I think that in 2020
through 2023, it was actually incredibly
like socially and financially lucrative
to not just be Destiny's orbiter, but
also to be Dylan Burns orbiter, Prime
Kai's Orbiter, Vos's orbiter, right?
there was like this really vibrant
debate space. And so I have nostalgia
about that time period and I have
nostalgia about Destiny. I have some
nostalgia about Vosch, believe it or
not. And I'm still very friendly with
Dylan and I'm still very friendly with
Prime. Um, but the truth is the scene is
kind of like dead, right? And so there's
not much of a clout boost to be gained
by like sweeping for Destiny and his
misdeeds. Um, okay. But there but there
is maybe like a utility because Twitch
and YouTube politics does have a few
hundred thousand young, you know,
dispossessed, angry, politically
motivated people. There is a utility to
trying to get those people to either do
something with their lives or volunteer
or whatever. And so the utility for me
is not in like, you know, I I need
Destiny's like quote unquote like money
or clout. The utility for me is whether
or not we try to get a few hundred of
these tens of thousands of souls to
actually go do some real. And it seems
like Stephen is the only person who's
done that so far. And so, uh, you know,
let's use the midterms as an example.
Okay. Um, coming up in the midterms,
there's going to be Hassan. We could we
could cut to the end of this. I like I I
don't need to hear I we've all heard
this exact explanation. Just breaks down
to the Jimmy Savile. Yeah. If he saves
two kids, he could rap one, right? like
you're just going to do the util thing.
We could we can go there. Like we could
skip to the end of it, right? I get that
like you think it's important that you
get people engaged and I get that you
don't have a replacement for Destiny,
but it's like I'm I'm sitting here and
it's like a whole bunch of people told
me like morally they're against doxing.
Morally they're against like viol like
encouraging violence online. I think
Erdite talked about how she wanted to
politically split from Destiny over some
of the rhetoric he was he was doing,
right? I just I wonder why like
essentially nobody called this guy out
when he just called for the death of
like multiple creators and then
justified calling for the death of those
creators repeatedly on his YouTube
channel. You know why? How does that not
risk?
I hold I'll tell you something. Uh
because it to me it was funny when it
happened with BLM with the Kyle
Writtenhouse thing. I was like based it
was kind of funny with the MAGA thing
where I was like yeah if you actually
believe that Trump is a fascist piece of
[__] who's about to destroy this country
then you shouldn't give a whether or not
one of his supporters gets shot in the
[__] face and I thought that was
funny too just being real. Um okay
whether or not like Steven legitimately
wants a schizophrenic to murder you guys
I have no idea if that's his true
intent. Um, and he's also using like
almost like a self-defense reasoning
that I don't know whether or not is
actually true. Uh, I and by the way,
this isn't like, oh, we we need him.
Like, like, no, I'm not saying that. We
don't need him. We don't need him for
the midterms. That's not my point at
all. Um, the the point is like I don't
know how much I give a about his or the
Discord. Like, so in order to verify
everything that you need to say or you
just said, I would need to like go into
Discord and then start trolling through
like pages of DMs of people who have no
Can I Can I ask you just really quickly?
Why did you accept whole cloth that
narrative from Destiny without any
investigation? Why did you ask for him
to accept the narrative? And I I don't
think I have accepted the narrative and
I don't know if I care to investigate
it. Okay? Because like my my work isn't
reliant on Destiny. what I'm going to do
over the next year isn't relying on
Destiny. Okay. All right. Uh, sure.
That's fine. No, but but but like but so
so let me ask let me ask you a question.
Are you on on some level this is
content, right? You're you're going to
clip it, post it. Conor's a hypocrite.
He's a piece of whatever. But well, I
mean, I'm trying to keep the actual tone
of the conversation away from that,
right? But but are you I'm asking you
because I'm trying to ask you on a human
level. Are you emotionally bothered that
there are creators like like Destiny? I
I I think you used to be a fan, right?
Are you emotionally bothered by the fact
that this person who got a lot of
charity from the Twitch and YouTube
politics space and who you used to be a
fan of is coming after you and nobody
seems to give a like does that bug you
emotionally or is it just like oh yeah
everybody's a hypocrite and a piece of
like what what what's I would say the
the bother um emotionally maybe is that
like nobody actually had principles on
any of these things when everybody soyed
out about Shauna Black and Mike from PA
and Gremlow calling for violence against
Destiny when everybody retweeted my
tweets saying, "Hey, it's really for you
to do this. This is insane, actually."
Right. I was the only person who
believed that. So, I spread that message
that that was bad. But actually, I'm ash
because nobody else gave a Did you
retweet those? Uh I I don't I don't know
if I retweeted those, but no, but they
like not liking general harassment and
violence doesn't mean that uh in certain
situations if you think that people
deserve it that that makes you
hypocritical. I don't think that's true.
Um sure, but then you're you're loading
this all into the conditional and saying
that you don't want to investigate the
conditional. you've actually like moved
the entire you've moved you've gotten
rid of the only question that exists is
whether or not like and I I would just
wonder why there's nobody who's like uh
kind of like close to not even close to
Destiny why there's aren't a lot of
people who like to investigate and
figure this out right well yeah yeah
yeah so no that that's actually again I
would just that's the practical thing so
so the practical thing is there there
there's three people involved right now
so let let's say that I want to
investigate this I want to get to the
bottom of this okay there there's three
people involved who would actually have
access to the information. One of them
would be Queman. Uh no offense to
Queman, but he's kind of like a and I
literally think that he lives to piss
off people so much that they wish death
on him. Like I think that's actually the
way that he operates. And so I think
that if I asked him, he would probably
be honest, but he also I don't think
he's going to like troll through his own
Discord in order to find me logs of
every schizophrenic that he's ever had
in the Discord to see whether or not one
of them went after Destiny or talked
about going after Destiny. I don't think
that he cares that much. Would that
justify this if there was a skits in
there who's like attached to human arms?
Would that like justify it? Let's say
yeah, if there was somebody in the chat
that was like, "Hey, yeah, lol. I just
got Destiny's girlfriend's docs blah
blah blah blah blah blah just
posted." And then Queen was like, "Hey,
bro. We don't post about that [__] here.
Uh, you know, otherwise awesome." You
know, like like, yeah, then I I would
see that. I think that potentially
justified in believing that they were
playing footsie in the back end, they
just didn't do it on Discord, right? Oh,
so even if Quimman had a policy that
like I'm going to delete that and I'm
going to get that person out of my
Discord or something, it wouldn't
matter. You would just believe that that
was happening behind the scenes then?
Um, uh, I think the kicked out of the
Discord would be the thing that I would
look to to see whether or not Queen
legitimately didn't believe in that
behavior. Like if if he banned him, then
I would be like, "Okay, he's probably
not playing footsie." Um if he didn't
ban him then I'd be like maybe he's
playing footsie, right? Doesn't that
make sense to some degree? Sure. Sure.
Um yeah, I would just say broadly using
like the justifications you've used that
like people could under your framework
you've presented here call for violence
against you based on essentially
anything, right? Like you've and like
you would have any moral condemnation
because you don't have a moral position
on this at all, right? If if they
thought it was justified, right? Yeah.
Like it's it's literally the Trump um
Trump thought he won the election. Trump
thought he won the election. So he was
totally justified in trying to take it
back because that's what he thought. He
had a truly held belief that he won the
election. So that was actually he's not
morally culpable for that decision to
try to take the election back, right?
No, I don't I don't think we're I don't
think we're saying the same thing. He
thought he was
justif. So, if I don't believes I don't
know if Steven earnestly believes that
he's in a self-defense situation and
he's acting out of like uh reciprocal
violence. I I don't I don't know if he
truly believes that or if there's just
people who are critical of him and he's
like, "Yeah, these people lol ruin their
lives. Who gives a I'm assuming that
you're saying it's the latter, right?"
Yeah. And so so my kind of my kind of
question is um if he if he were in a
like a self-defense style situation so
to speak then he could be potentially
justified because if I if we did find
DMs of people at from KF you know
playing footsie in your chat and
Queman's chat then it would be
reciprocal. Now the easiest way to
resolve that I think is to ask Stephen.
Um, but I but I almost guarantee you
that he's in such a sensitive spot that
if I'm asking for that, then he's just
just gonna be like, "Oh, okay. Well,
you're a part of them, so you too." So,
yeah. So, so then that you're basically
in the same position as all the victims
who are like, "Yeah, I'd speak up, but
uh actually might just put me on a
target list." I mean, I don't care if
I'm on a target list. Um, okay. As a
matter of fact, it why not? Why not?
I'll literally just DM them. And again,
I just want to I need proof that I was
like somehow aware of this, right? Like
I don't spend very much time on my
Discord. I would have to be aware of
this. Okay. Yeah. Give me Let me think
about how I want to phrase this real
quick. I'll try not to leave too much
there. You could you could just send it
after if you want. Like I I'll believe
you after now just because I don't want
to um
you know whatever consistency we can
glean from the conversation. I kind want
to do it now. Um Jay Stock and I are on
a call in order for it to be justifi or
for your docs for death to be justified
the um what is it the plain footsie with
KF docpin would need like I've literally
I don't think I've ever been on docin
before so sure we need to be I'm totally
unaware of that site there But do you
have any hard evidence of
him/queenman
playing with those psychos?
Like the closest thing I could think is
basically the guy Oh, hold on. I'm just
going to tell you the closest thing I
could think of is maybe he could say
that the solo guy originally shopped
like the the original Lauren leaks in
Queens Discord, but like I told Destiny
about that. Like I gave him a heads up
on that. So I don't even know. Like I
gave him a heads up before Sunday went
live. And and maybe that'll be it. Maybe
he'll just say, "Oh yeah, you know, this
this solo leaked it in their chat and
that'll be all of it." Which would
declined to cover it. Yeah. Like Queen
declined to cover it. Um the guy
happened to find someday, but like I
don't even know. Yeah, Queen deleted all
of them. He declined to cover it. I
don't know what more was expected there,
but yeah. Anyway, yeah, indulge me
another rant. Okay, so macroing this
out. Uh we there was and is a late
30-year-old man who is a gooner who had
sex with a bunch of women. The was
consensual. The video recording was
consensual, but then he took those video
recordings and he said it without their
consent to a bunch of people. Right?
Then allegedly he audio recorded
consensual counter encounters without
those people's consent and then he sent
that around. Right? that that's what
happened as far as I understand right
now. What's going on is in the wake of
those revelations of him engaging in
reckless sec uh behavior that damaged
the public reputation of a bunch of
people. Uh habitual consent violations.
The most accurate way I've heard of
saying it, habitual consent violations,
I would say, but they weren't all. So,
okay. Um, yeah, he's basically saying
that he doesn't have the time or energy
or interest in order to substantiate.
And he basically says that if I go into
your stuff and then I just search for
his name and his girlfriend's name, then
I'm just going to find dozens upon
dozens of people effectively just
pouring over every detail of their
lives. You might find people going over
like some details of their lives. I
think people Kelly was like mad at his
girlfriend, right? after he had made up
a bunch of malicious lies about Kelly. I
think Kelly started attacking his
girlfriend, but is that a reason again?
Would that be would that be reason to
dox me and then my death? Uh, and pro
probably not the the thing. So, here's
my thing though. So, so I think I did I
accurately summarize the drama
relatively speaking. Uh, I mean I Yeah,
I'd have like some superficial
disagreements, right? But it's fine as a
fine summary. So, so in the wake of that
scenario, we have because correct me if
I'm wrong, you what? You get like what
highund so like 700s 800 live viewers
somewhere in there depending on I no I
haven't gotten 800 in a while like um I
yeah I I'm at 550 right now. Okay. Which
I guess is not that bad considering
there's a bunch of other people live but
go ahead. Sure sure. So So you're
between 500 and a thousand live view
live streamer. Queman is also between
500 and a,000 uh live viewers. God bless
his soul. Good for him. Grinding. Uh the
So there's two communities that Stephen
is alleging in the wake of this drama
have made it their effectively their
life's mission in order to endlessly
talk about him and pray on his d
downfall, hope he goes to jail, hope he
gets all his money taken away from him,
hope he gets his uh his platform taken
away from him, etc., etc. And so you're
saying that we but these communities as
far as you understand are playing within
the rules of the internet as you
understand them whereas Stephen is
violating them in order to come after
you and Queen. So now we have a late
40-year-old man who has indiscretions
and we have two communities of several
hundred people who are going after him
and he's going allegedly harder than
they are. At what point that this this
is going to be a little, you know,
dismissive. At what point do I, as an
almost 40-year-old man with two children
and bills to pay and a different job
that focuses on different [__] at what
point do I just say, "You're all
repulsive." And I just walk away. Um, I
mean, you could have done that at any
point. I just thought you like literally
do streaming. You've had these moral
conversations. You've taken moral
positions, right? So, it's basically me
asking you what's changed in your moral
positions. And I don't feel like you've
actually given me satisfactory answers
on any of that. Right. Sure. Um, you
could you could just opt for that, but
if if that was the decision you're going
to make, I feel like you wouldn't keep
entertaining these conversations. No, I
I believe it or not, I I entertain these
conversations because a lot of people
when I entered Twitch and YouTube
politics, whenever I asked for a
conversation, they just said yes. And so
I try to have a pretty open door policy
when it comes to conversations because
oftentimes like if you if you're not
willing to have the conversation it just
looks like you're right. Um and then it
anyways it h rising tides help raise all
boats right so if a lot of people said
yes to me they helped me with my YouTube
career they helped me with my stream if
somebody asked me for a conversation I
want to say yes. So, uh, the this
question or let me answer your first
question and then maybe we can move to
the the second question if there is a
second question. Um, I think I took a
note on it earlier. You asked me what's
the difference between doxing is one of
the worst things you can do. I still
think doxing is one of the worst things
you can do. Uh, one of the parties is
claiming self-defense and I'm not sure
if I believe them and I think I need to
think about it then. I I think the
second thing is the death threats. I do
think it actually is supered up for him
to be like I would kill them. I would I
would choke them out if I could. It is
kind of like a Xanderhal moment. That's
like embarrassing. Sorry. That's
embarrassing. I would say the
combination of them and not saying well
he said both I choke them out if I could
and I really want somebody to go kill
these people, right? I really want
someone to kill these guys. So I'd say
the combination of trying to like doing
his best to post identities and calling
for the death. I think that combination
is from the same person through his own
accounts is pretty insane and like an
escalation that's not really a similar
escalation. I don't even think he did
that to like Keles or something. Ke's
got his tush taken away. So the Yeah. So
the in in reference to that if I was the
person that was on the receiving end of
that I would assume that we talked about
like stochcastic verbiage for a really
long time uh in Twitch and YouTube
politics. If somebody did that to me, I
would assume effectively assume that
they were trying to like stochastically
inspire one of their schizophrenic
community members to either harass me.
Yeah. Either harass me, do death
threats, or even show up to my place and
either try to scare me or actually
injure me. Sure. Yeah. Do you um just
out of curiosity, do you have any of the
recent stream clips from him justifying
it after the fact? Uh there's his
justification with you and then there
was one where he's playing Factorio the
other day that I don't have off the top
of my head. Hold on. Okay. Is it is it
in a is it in a similar I do have it off
the top of my head. Boom. Should I click
watch stream? Yeah, click watch stream
or let me uh I just need to fix up OBS
real quick. I won't have it off of him.
Just saw a video where everyone losing
their mind that just threatened to kill
just somebody cuz the I have like three
communities on ALS that are obsessively
upote down voting all my [__] Um,
people are I think I don't even remember
this. Oh, can you rewind? Thank you for
the five seconds. Can you rewind five
seconds? I'll restart it. I'll restart
it.
Decades. Real quick though, I'm just
going to do a show real quick since I've
got most of my audience here. Uh, guys,
if you like the content, go ahead and
throw me a couple subs. Throw me a
couple bucks. Exclamation boy. Donate in
the chat. We'll give you the donation
links. Okay, you can go join the Patreon
as well.
patreon.com/jslk. Any support you give
is appreciated and adds time to the
stream. Thank you very much. Okay, let's
go. It's not just saw a video where
everyone losing their mind that Destiny
threatened to kill just somebody because
I have like three communities on LSF
that are obsessively upote down voting.
Oh my [__] People are say up vote down
vote up vote down voting. He's saying
that like uh he's getting astroturf down
votes on LSF.
Okay.
Stalin a slot. Thank you for the 5k.
This was like months ago. But somebody
basically asked me I think Willy Mack
asked me something like oh like how do
you feel about Oh you messaged him while
he was live on anything else. Apparently
brought it up there too. uh these people
whatever and I was like if you're
somebody that is actively engaged in a
community that is like spam linking
revenge of me revenge uh docs of me docs
of so revenge of me docs of
me neither of those things have ever
been done hold on so revenge of me and
and sorry I'm I'm writing these down
revenge of me docs of me cyber drifter
thank you for the 10 gifted let's go a
community there's like spam linking
revenge of me revenge uh docs of me docs
of my girlfriend revenge for my like if
you're doing all so docs of me revenge
of me docs of my girlfriend revenge one
of my girlfriend um none of those things
I I believe have ever been linked to my
discord I think um I don't recall it
happening and people have said it didn't
happen but like it wouldn't shock me if
somebody got really overzealous and
posted like some clip from her uh my
free cams or something um I don't think
that would be revenge like
you're selling on the internet
necessarily. Um, and Destiny did the
same thing to Kelly Gene, posting her
Only Fans content in his DG chat. So,
I'm not sure. Wait, sorry, say that very
last sentence again. Uh, Destiny also
posted only fans content from Kelly Jean
in his DG chat. And that was before she
allegedly posted pictures of heroid
butthole. I don't I don't know if it was
before after. And I don't know if she
posted that. I don't think she posted
that, but she says she didn't. I have no
idea. I have not investigated to know
for sure. Okay. So where? Let let me ask
let me ask you the So I I believe her
when she says she did. Okay. So let me
let me ask you this question. So we got
uh allegedly. Okay. Allegedly. We got
Lav uh posting pictures of Destiny as a
Discord username on a Discord with like
a few dozen or a few hundred people,
right? I think we got Kelly Jean as a
part of that Discord. Even if she
doesn't do that. Nope. Kelly Jean was
not a part of that Discord. That's made
up as far as I know. Okay. Then we have
Kelly Jean at least making fun of his
girlfriend's butthole. Yep. Uh then we
have Quean and yourself. None of the
love content conduct happened on my
Discord, by the way. Sure. It it was
just Lav I I I think he's saying that uh
you platformed and by the way I don't
give a [__] I'm saying what he said.
Platformed uh Mr. Girl and Lav. Did you
platform Mr. Girl? Um after all this bro
What did Mr. girl. Wait, why why would I
be able to get doxed for Mr. Girl being
platformed? Uh, just because this is
like the the cabal of people who are
praying on Destiny's downfall. Okay, I
platform Mr. Girl with other people with
Dan and Allrele relevant in the call
pushing back against what he was saying,
by the way. No, no, I'm not adding this
up to a case where I think it's
appropriate. Um, I'm trying to I'm
trying to follow the logic chain, so to
speak. I'm just pointing out how the
logic chain is. Sure. as and then and
then effectively I guess the insinuation
is that queen in your communities
communities have to be partially made up
of people who love perusing and posting
to Kiwi Farms. But I also think that
that's like that's kind of an unfair
charge, right? Cuz if you're a bigger
streamer entirely have schizophrenics in
your chat? Yeah. Well, and my community
is built entirely from his community.
And my community has like the same like
most active chatters that it's had since
I've basically first started streaming.
Yeah. So, so the question is, have you
done anything sufficiently to the point
besides being the people who are praying
on Steven's downfall, have you done
anything sufficiently to the point that
warrants doxing or threats of violence?
And I will say when Kelly posted that
stuff in the Discord, um Lena, Destiny's
girlfriend, reached out to me and based
on the stream conversation we had said,
"Thank you for defending me and saying
like, "You don't appreciate that. You
don't want that around." right and
basically pushing back on anything Kelly
was saying and saying it was like crazy.
Um, people in the Discord broadly push
back against Kelly like attacking his
girlfriend as well. The overall tenor of
the Discord is no, we don't do that
here. Um, and Destiny knows that for a
fact, but he will lie about it. Yeah,
then I mean Yeah, then I I think I think
I can I can land on I can understand
emotionally how Steven would land on a
point where he's like, "Yeah, it all
these people." But I also think that
he's just incorrect. Um, I I I think
Yeah. Yeah, I'll just I'll just say that
I I think that he's incorrect to be
doxing obviously for all the reasons
that I listed of why we have the rules
that we have unwritten, but the rules
that we have as creators. And then I
think he's also wrong to stochcastically
call for your potential death or
Queenman's potential death because I
don't think in so far as the behaviors
that I've observed and know of um all of
this feels like part of the game. Well,
I mean it's so it's maybe it's part of
the game. Um you guys went over the Anna
stuff as well. I'd love to go over that
with you before we uh wrap this up, but
it's it's broadly just his pattern. He's
going to try to like terrorize the
people who have criticisms for him. It's
just broadly the pattern that exists,
right? It's what he did to Anavar. Um
you It's weird cuz you did the whole Mr.
Girl report review. I think you went
through theore section and then when
Destiny said I didn't do anything like
manipulative um it literally says that
they were 2 days before he posted her
Kiwi Farms thing and then he goes well I
didn't do that to like with her I did
that to like get it out of my community
and then when we go to the DMs like if
you want to stay in this uh um when we
go to the DMs like I'll read you the DMs
it's it's quite literally like hey if
you if you stop uh this yourself yeah up
here. Okay, so the the DMs Anna says,
"What the is wrong with you, dude? You
just outed that Kiwi Farm about me,
dude. You are horrible." He says, "I
have a media blackout related to your
stuff, and I wanted to get everyone Oh,
I'm covering this up for stream." Well,
you guys aren't going to see it. You'll
see Conor's face. I have a media
blackout related to your stuff and I
wanted to everyone to get it out before
uh people were talking about it
incessantly over the next two weeks as
more and more people discovered it which
is like okay you are constantly the
second paragraph is where um when he
says oh I didn't do it to like make her
stop talking but I didn't do it to do
you are constantly talking about me on
your stream so I think it's fair for me
to bring it up you went as far to say I
I was abusive to you the last time you
mentioned me she says because you
threatened to leak my no news you
sociopath you literally ruined my life
you just dox me on stream you you put me
in danger. You're doing it. He says,
"You're doing it to yourself." You're
going to keep doing it to yourself. When
you keep talking about me, even if I say
something like, "I'm going to leak your
nudes if you talk about me anymore." Uh,
you're doing it to yourself, actually.
So, I would say this is very much, "Hey,
you have to stop what you're doing and I
will dox you and terrorize you." And I'm
justified in doing that because you have
talked about me. And uh, sorry, what was
the characterization? His
characterization 2 days. Show me anytime
I'm trying to manipulate a narrative or
manipulate somebody into like silence.
trying to get Anna to shut the up. Um,
okay. We can watch the here. We can
watch the clip on it if you like, but
it's like name a time I've show evidence
of my manipulation. I would say this is
very manipulative. Um, like the
oppressor oppressy dynamic that because
a person might be smaller than me or
whatever, I'm not allowed to say
anything back. I reject that framework.
And so, everybody thinks he's allowed to
say something back. He's allowed to look
at their statements and then respond to
those statements, right? Reveal
information that responds to those
statements. I would say responding or
I'm not oh it's they're a small creator
so I'm not allowed to do anything back
does mean probably I mean doesn't really
matter the size of the creator probably
your response to somebody saying
incorrect things about you shouldn't be
to dox them or post their docs and
amplify their docs right okay entirely
um I would say from now on um and I've
said this for a while although my
personal life isn't as much in the
spotlight anymore if you want to
criticize me for being like manipulative
or controlling or some then you need to
post examples of that it's not enough to
just say oh because Destiny He spoke
about this on stream. He's abusing his
power. That's um so I would say the
example of him being abusive here is
that he was her two days before he
posted he he said on stream, "Here's her
Kiwi Farms thread." Right. Right. Yeah.
So, just uh just giving you the read.
I'm not saying that you don't have an
accurate read. I'm saying that u I want
to I want to show you my thought
process. So the first paragraph, I have
a media blackout related to your stuff
and I wanted everyone to get it out
before people were talking about it
incessantly over the next two weeks as
more and more people discovered it. That
uh could like hypothetic, not
hypothetically, uh theoretically could
be the narrative of I didn't want it on
my subreddit. I didn't want it in my
community, so I wanted to burn it out in
Kiwi Farms instead of having it leak
into my community. That that's however
Sorry. Go ahead. We We both know that's
the most thing either of us has ever
heard, right? If I if I went and said,
"Okay, why you think some new Revenge of
Destiny just leaked? I'm going to direct
you guys to it and I'm going to give you
a link to it because I don't want you
talking about it in my community. I want
you to go talk about it on the subreddit
or on the message board where it is,
right? That would be an insane thing to
do." No. So that this is where you you
can call me I'm going to explain my
logic. dramas seem to come and go uh no
matter how bad they are and the faster
they get consumed, the faster they get
burnt out. So I can almost see the logic
of I want this to burn out and I want
this to burn out away from me. Like can
I just point out as an example um Hunter
Avalone had one of the craziest dramas
that's ever happened ever. I have not
heard that brought up in the last 12
months except for a retrospective by
Chud. You know what I'm saying? Like
like even even the worst burns out.
Okay, that was all information that was
like released. It was like embarrassing,
but it's not like personally uh
endangering material, right? Unless
you're talking about him ending himself,
but I would say that broadly like that
also propagated through normal channels,
right? I don't know. Like to me to me
again the hypothetical I'm giving you is
I can't I can't burn out Destiny's new
tape leaks or revenge leaks by saying
here that here's the link don't talk
about it anymore right that would be I
I'm just going to ask you to say that
that's I want you to tell me that that's
insane please no that yeah that that's
crazy pants cuz obviously even if it
even if it's majority in the opposite
community it's going to spread
everywhere else. Uh yeah. No, I I get
that. I I get that. It's uh it's Can I
ask you? Well, so so can you can you
bridge a gap for me? So if they're if
they're two days
before, what happened in those 48 hours
for this like about face? What was it
like an Anna stream where she's like I
am guessing Anna said something. I'm
guessing Anna said something and then he
said if she's going to leak any of my
details because I remember this. I'm
guessing is if he if she leaks any of my
details, I will um I'll leak stuff about
him, right? Or sorry, I'll leak stuff
about her nudes or some [__] Yeah, I
remember people defending that. I think
this is before I got into the community,
so little sparse details there. Yeah.
So, let me uh let's try to macro it.
Let's try to macro it a little bit. Can
you hold on to your thought? I don't
know if I could hold on to mine. What's
that? Sorry. Can you can you hold on to
your thought cuz I don't know if I could
hold on to mine. I just want to point
out, yeah, go ahead. Why would why would
Destiny himself need to burn out
anything from Kiwi Farms unless he had
Kiwi farmers in his chat who would be
following it and looking for the link
and posting the link and then which is
the sin he's currently accusing you of.
Yeah. So, okay, I I'm tracking and I'm
absorbing and I'm uh I'm groing. Okay.
I'm I'm processing information. Let
Let's uh let's kind of like resummarize
just so I can ground myself. Yeah. You
want to go? I I had that conversation
with Stephen because obviously this
drama happened. A lot of people wanted
me to take like a really harsh stance
really early on. I refused obviously and
then things have kind of settled a
little bit, but they're still simmering
in the background because we have the
pending lawsuit, etc. The reason why I
wanted to have that conversation is
because I was genuinely curious what his
moral uh philosophy and system was like
in 2022 versus what it was like or what
it is now. And while I feel like we
discussed the overall like I don't know
hedenism, stoicism, the 11 arisatilian
virtues, how he perceives his moral
obligations separate from his pleasure
seeeking, we really didn't get in my
opinion a definitive separation between
his previous philosophy and his current
philosophy. And so that's scary. you
know, a as a friendly associate of his.
Uh, I think that's obviously scary
because then that means that like
despite all of the negative consequences
that have occurred as a result of what I
would call pleasure- seeeking behavior,
that still means that it's quite
possible that it could happen again,
right? Because he he would think that
like, oh, I I have my moral obligations
and my pleasure seeeking perfectly
attuned. Therefore, uh, what I'm doing
right now is perfectly fine. But then
he's just jumping on another rake that
smashes him in the face. Um, yeah. So,
that's scary. I'll say that's scary as a
as a friendly associate of Stevens. But
then but then I guess like what what is
your you've kind of rebutted his
accusation. What else uh should we be
addressing? Uh, so I wanted to go
through the Anna thing and just point
out that like clearly that's like when
you I felt like you would push back more
there. And you could say like your focus
was just not on um basically what when
he was addressing individual pieces or
something because you wanted to have a
broad philosophy talk. I just would have
expected when you went over the Mr. Girl
report like a month before that to kind
of have this in your head and know that
basically like this is this is probably
insane. And it is like it is a part of a
pattern of behavior. This pattern of
behavior has repeated itself for years
right at this point and it's shown no
real that there's contrition or any real
change needs to be made. Yeah. And and
I've given up on contrition by the way.
Uh, the reason why I've given up on
contrition is because I've kind of come
to the whether regardless of whether or
not I like him or regardless of whether
or not I work with him in the future, I
don't know if he's psychologically
capable of contrition. Uh, the the way
that I think normal psychology works is
you up, you realize you up, you feel
guilty, you feel a little bit of shame,
you apologize, you atone, you show that
you're contrite, and then regardless of
whether or not that person forgives you,
you move on. That's like the normal
cycle, right? But I think that with
Stephen's pleasure seeeking, I'm just
gonna be very honest. I I think that
with his pleasure- seeeking behavior, uh
he might be abusive, but he also
attracts uh either personalities that
are attracted to abuse or personalities
that they themselves are abusive in
certain ways. And so as a result, he
always has a justification for why the
opposite party is incorrect and wrong
and deserving of his wrath. And so he'll
always have a narrative of how they did
him wrong and why they deserve the poor
treatment that he's meeting out to them.
Indulge me just one more rant. Part of
the reason why I asked about the turn
the other cheek Christian philosophy and
I also asked about do unto others as you
would like to be done unto you versus do
unto others as they do unto you. Uh is
because I think that Steven operates
under the latter and if he wanted to end
the cycle of abuse he would go to the
former. Sure. He doesn't operate on the
latter either though. He operates on
like the is it the untouchables? um send
one of ours to the hospital, we send one
of yours to the morg. That's like the
standard he operates on, right? Like no
matter what you do to me, the thing he
actually accused and projected onto
Kelly Jean where he was like, "Oh, you
just escalate an insane amount." Uh he
just escalates an insane amount, right?
Basically always like without any
concern for control or how it looks to
anybody around him. And then he'll try
to justify it and because he's built up
like a cult-like audience. And just like
you said, you actually described this
because there's actually a second sphere
around Destiny that's not just his
audience, but it's like the uh enjoined
like Twitch politics sphere that's all
used to the way he makes arguments. Very
very um they'll be listening with an
open ear for the way he makes arguments
and they will basically agree with him
when he's saying insane things. I think
that happened to you in this
conversation where like he's just like,
"Yeah, um like I don't want to get into
it, but basically there's some people
who are like kind of attached to
something that's kind of attached to
Kiwi Farms." And so even though Jay-Z
might not be aware of any of it and even
though Queen might not be aware of any
of it, um yeah, I I am going to dox them
and tell people to kill them. And it's
like that's that's an insane sequence of
statements to make and then people kind
of just nod and go, "Oh, yeah, that
makes sense." Well, and the the claim
the claim is uh do unto others as they
are doing to you, but that if you were
going to follow that moral system, then
of course you would actually have to
prove that others are currently doing
that to you. And then but but this is
where this is where it gets uh to my
sympathy and my empathy, right? The I
sympathize and empathize with people who
have been like docs, harassed, whatever.
You know, I've had a few ugly messages.
I've had a few people say some nasty
things to me. Uh but I I haven't had
anybody show up to my house. I haven't
had anybody swap my house. I haven't had
anybody uh threatened death to my wife
or kids. I used to as a law enforcement
officer, but I haven't had that as a
streamer or a YouTuber. And so I'm
actually sympathetic to that part of it.
And I also understand that when you're
under threat, pretty much everything
feels like a threat. And so I I don't
know if he I don't want to go so far as
to say like he's
consciously appealing to my empathy and
sympathy for the amount of harassment
he's endured over the past like year and
a half. Um, but I would say that like it
makes a certain amount of emotional
sense. So even if you and Quean aren't
part of the cabal that's attacking him,
you are, I don't know, attacking his
public reputation and praying on his
downfall. And therefore, you're getting
swept into the many people who have been
harassing him wrongly or rightly over
the past two years. Yeah. But then to me
that's like uh I would hope that the
people he's close to andor that he like
um would somewhat care about the
opinions of would basically go that's
insane because that opens all of us that
that means everything that's been done
to him is also justified right now that
he's done this he is he has said that it
is actually fine his behavior has put
everybody else around him at risk right
and like now based on his own
justification not mine I I strictly say
over and over and over again I don't
advocate for any collateral damage
damage. That's not my MO. I don't like
that. If I have a problem with somebody,
I'll go after them. Right. But he is now
going for he's basically got people on
Kiwi farms that he's blaming me for
their behavior, right? And now I'm
collateral damage. He's just he's just
green lit everything on everybody else
and he has no moral leg to stand on. We
probably agree on that, right? That if
anybody can be connected to him and his
system of abuse, he now Yeah. Unless he
was somehow able to substantiate that
you were like knowingly playing footsie
with the most nefarious parts of Kiwi
farms who were actively engaging in
swatting and doxing of him and his
girlfriend. Unless that link was
established, then yeah, I I don't I
under the moral philosophy of do unto
others as they are doing unto you,
you're that that's not even correct
under that philosophy, which I think is
not a great philosophy. Sure. Yeah. So,
no, I'm I'm with you. I'm with you. And
uh what what I would say is let's just
uh macro it. Um from a a moral
evaluation standpoint, I think that if
he's going to publicly say that he is
not only okay, he is encouraging you,
Kelly Jean, and Queen to be doxed and he
thinks that you're playing cute with uh
nefarious communities. I think that he
needs to establish that link or else
it's wrong. Like like totally wrong.
flat wrong and even then it's probably
not a good thing. It's not it's not
morally it's not the best moral system.
I would just say it has to link to me
and then like I can I could probably
show you logs. I'm I'm sure I could go
find in my mod chat somewhere where we
like banned links to KF or any images
from KF because it was like oh people
are starting to post. No, we don't want
that. We don't want that like
association, right? So it's like yeah
and there has to be reasonability. You
you can you can only reasonably do so
much, right? That I I think that and
he's a creator. He understands that he
has schizophrenic parts of his audience.
He can't police every single bad thing
that DGGers say. Uh so if he understands
that he cannot police all of the
negative behavior of DGG, then he needs
to understand that you and Que can't
police all of the negative behavior of
your respective communities. Yeah. And I
guess then his only leg to stand on them
would probably be me having Kelly Gene
on stream while she was talking [__]
about his girlfriend. But again, she
wasn't like doxing her or calling for
threats on her or anything like that.
she was just talking [__] and like and
broadly the community as a whole pushed
back against her almost entirely, right?
So it's like the the thing he's talking
about is the the core of the community
is like these Kiwi farmers or doxers,
but basically everybody was like,
"Please don't do that." Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. I I think I think I'm
landing on solid ground psychologically,
even if it took me a while to get there.
So, uh what I would say, and by the way,
if you want to give me something else
mentally, uh that's totally fine. But
what I would say I would advocate
publicly is obviously Christian morality
which is turn the other cheek when you
can and also do unto others as you want
done unto you. I think that Destiny's
philosophy of eye for an eye and tooth
for a tooth and then some is obviously
not working out and I would say that
it's hurting people and we've been
dealing with two or three years of the
fallout of what he did in 2022. And so I
think it's time for the cycle of
[__] to stop. So he my
recommendation to him would be to stop
the [__] And if you're going to be
reciprocal, if you're going to advocate
for violence, if you're going to
advocate for doxing, then you need to
actually establish the evidence that
justifies you morally, or else I think
people should would have uh correct
cause to doubt. Yeah. And like
realistically, I'm sure he's going to
find people who in my Discord have made
like references to things on Kiwi Farms,
but it's like where's the what am I
supposed to do? Like I like you'd have
to have Yeah. some reasonability there.
I I don't know. Like people might do
memes. I we do the 17-year-old meme,
right? that how old was Rose? But like
realistically, I talked to Destiny. Solo
talked to me as well. And I talked to
Destiny about Solo and Destiny was the
one who said because I I actually tried
to protect Destiny. I I tried to call
him. I actually said, "Don't I'm not
going to put this in text because it's
like concerning to me." I tried to call
him and he's like, "Oh, it's about the
underage thing, right?" And I was like,
"Yeah, this solo guy who leaked your
just told me that this girl's 17. Was 17
when you first started getting news from
her?" And he's like, "Oh yeah, she he
told me that, too." He's like, "Yeah,
I'm not not really sure about that. He
thought she was 19." Just to be clear,
I'm not saying he thought she was 17.
Um, but he he expressed that like he did
an ID check. He joked a lot about her
age, right? And he did an ID check, knew
she lived with her parents. There's like
a lot of concerning things there. So, we
meme about that, but that's all from
primary sources. That's from like
Destiny himself saying that he didn't
know how old she was. He didn't do an ID
check. He didn't know much about her.
So, like I Right. And yeah, and and this
is where I would in a in a correlative
way, I would say that uh if if we were
to take the most dry description of this
behavior, I would say that in 2022,
Destiny's pleasure-seeking behavior was
out like like insane. And uh he he
forsook his moral obligations to the
broader community. And then he's saying
that he's recalibrated that in the
modern era. Uh but we need to see that
evidenced and I I don't think a good way
to evidence that is by saying anybody
who criticizes my not even criticizes my
previous behavior but uh basically
anybody who comes after me for my bad
behavior in the past uh you know if you
associate with schizophrenics then I'm
going to unleash a schizophrenic mob
upon you. I don't I don't know if that's
the best way to turn a new leaf. And I
think you'd have to agree that I would
be totally justified in trying to go to
like YouTube, like trying to email
people at YouTube about this, him like
justifying death threats against me on
his stream, right? I would be totally
fine creating like a packet of
information for future political
collaborations that I could say, "Hey,
just so you know, this is the guy you're
engaging with. These are the behaviors
he undertakes." I think all of that
would be totally fair game, right? The
the T So when it comes to the the toos
or whatever, you know, we're we're all
slaves to it, so I get it. Um, I get it.
I didn't I didn't say I was going to do
those things. I am incredibly anti
flagged. Even when he tried to mass flag
me for using an F-sler about him on
stream when I was describing how he had
uh non-conensually recorded a friend of
mine when I when I did it one time and
he called for mass flagging my channel,
I still said don't do anything in
return. It's whatever. We should leave
it alone. But now it's gotten to like an
insane extent and I think I would be
totally justified. I haven't really
thought about it that much, but ju just
out of curiosity, do you think if you
emailed him he would ever talk to you?
Uh, probably. Probably. You think he
would? I think so. Have you considered
that as a course of option or course of
action? No. Why not? I'm not talking
about private. Uh, I was talking about
public, but either way, I Why not? I
don't know why I would want to. Why
would you want to? What What does he
have left to threaten me with? How How
can he like I don't need to He's already
done everything. It's actually threats.
Okay. It's not about threats. The This
is a weird perspective, but it's true.
oftentimes when I'm when I'm dealing
with uh people who are being terrible,
uh I'm probably thinking most about my
time in law enforcement. Um I I
oftentimes tried to give them outs,
right? I tried to, you know, re, you
know, reach out to them, you know,
mentally, emotionally, socially,
whatever, and try to say like, "Hey,
man, like you're you're up in this way,
that way, the other way. There's another
way that we could do this. Here's the
other way that we could do this. Let's
talk about it." And sometimes there
would be people who would take an out
and then as a result we would, you know,
avoid worse consequences and then
sometimes there are people who just
absolutely insisted on doing things the
hard way and as a result we did things
the hard way. And so that's where for me
if we're effectively summarizing the
fact that Destiny had horrible
indiscretions and then there's a drama
fallout between his critics and himself
and he's engaging in ways that you know
if you wanted to see him turn over a new
leaf, he's not engaging in those ways,
saying that to his face could be the
difference. So it could be the
difference between him turning a new
leaf and him not. Okay.
Um, I don't think I'm the person who
could do that. Uh, not after you said
all the He would need to he would need
to make amends, right, in some way. No.
Uh, yeah. Why Why wouldn't you be Why
would you be able to say, "Hey, these
are all the ways that I think you're up.
These are all the ways that I think
you're over me, uh, me over and other
people over. Um, here's everything that
you've morally justified, and here's all
the things that I think I would be
morally justified in doing to you based
off of your current behavior. Do you
want to talk about it?" Sure. He can't
escalate anymore on me. That doesn't
matter. I'm not talking about
escalating. It does matter to me that he
I'm almost talking about deescalating.
Oh, I know. But I'm saying that what
what reason do I have to deescalate
right now because hopefully he would be
because because he's not he's barring
new revelations. He's not going
anywhere. Like he will have a community.
He will have tens of thousands of live
viewers. He will be a a portion of
Twitch and YouTube. Will that community
ever not hate me? It doesn't matter. Who
cares? They hate me and I'm like the I I
I went in there with kids gloves and
they still hate me. Who cares? Um I am
not really interested in with no Yeah.
Like broadly this guy is just acting
like a deranged lunatic and endangering
all of his stuff. And realistically with
the uh hurt he's caused to a lot of
people around me, I'm I'm like fine with
that. Uh if he if he's going to take
shots at me and Queman and a couple
other people, um he's done it now. You
can't really do anything about it,
right? He's done it now. I'm like, okay,
I actually feel like what's that? What
about future people? I don't think he'll
ever stop. I don't think he'll ever stop
until he's forced to stop, until he sees
consequences. And I don't think he's
seen major consequences yet. So, you you
think he's irredeemably down this path
and there's no changing course? No. But
I think he is accepting he need he is
like years of therapy away from
meaningfully changing as a person,
right? Like he needs to he needs to
maybe not I don't know if stepping away
is the right idea, but he needs to
basically like admit some wrongdoing um
and make some like do some
acknowledgement that he's lived his life
in like a totally incorrect way and that
things need to change. But there's been
nothing like that, right? You can
say psychology would allow him to do
that. I don't think his psychology allow
him to do that. Then I think then I do
think if his if you're just going to say
his psychology won't allow him to do
that. If I take that assertion which I
don't believe but if I were to take that
assertion then he is actually
irredeemable, right? He will keep doing
this. So yeah. So let me let me explain
something at least as far as I
understand it. Okay. So when it come I I
don't know if he's like a a diagnosible
sociopath or psychopath but often times
with sociopathic people psychopathic
people they can still judge like moral
goods and bads uh they but they often
operate from a sense of self-interest
right okay and so when it comes to a
sense of self-interest if you're able to
you know Stephen in my opinion is
somebody who values uh rhetoric logic
all that kind of stuff he can be erratic
at times s. Um, but he does he does
value that, right? And so having someone
one of his most ardent critics coming to
him and logically laying out all of the
ways in which he's up and saying like,
"Hey man, like you're you're not only
hurting everyone else, you're hurting
your yourself, which he should realize
already, but it just might be different
having his one of his most ardent
critics laying out his sins before him."
Um, I think that would be an opportunity
to say, "Oh, well, this isn't just
hurting everyone else. This is also
hurting me." I don't have any belief
that any change of his with no like I
don't I would never believe that he's
changing, right? Like, broadly, he has
just been able to get away with this and
to like threaten other people into
stopping covering him, stopping talking
about him, stop pursuing whatever
they're pursuing against him, right?
It's just a consistent pattern over
time. I have no particular interest in
changing him. You can do it. Molina and
Dan tried for years. Sure. Yeah. I just
like I like literally What? Have you
watched Destiny's content at any point
where there isn't somebody in his life?
Molina, not so erodite. I'm sure I'm
sure going back to like Yellow Spoon
Girl and some other people. People being
like, "Hey, you can't I brought it up in
that conversation. I remember I remember
Molina saying that if you continue to
engage with drama content this way, then
you're going to lose everyone that's
close to you." I remember that quote
almost vividly. Okay. So, no, no, I'm
I'm with you. And and I actually uh this
might be a little personal, but I'll
just say it anyways cuz the truth hurts,
right? Um when this drama unfolded uh I
was talking to my wife about it and I
told her it's like this would be the
equivalent of losing I have a friend
named Tony. I love him like a brother
and then I have my wife obviously. So if
I if I had done something and I had lost
my wife and I had lost Tony, they said
you did something so up that we can't be
around you, then I wouldn't be looking
for anyone to blame but myself because
they're such fundamentally good people
that I would know that I had [__] up.
Right? So if you're losing the people
who are most important to you in your
life, then that's not an evaluation of
all of their sins, that should be an
evaluation of your sins. Yeah, this is
our relevant said something like this um
around the first day that Dan was like,
"Wait, um like don't you think as a
friend you have like a responsibility to
stick by your guy?" And our relevant
responded, "No, he had a responsibility
not to engage in these acts like he's
the leader of my political project. He's
he's like one of my friends or at least
I think we're friends or whatever. Like
we're friendly and he had a
responsibility to like at the people
around him to not act like this to not
do these things and he failed like it's
not. So I'm agreeing with you by the way
just in case that wasn't obvious. No,
that's fine. Yeah. Uh maybe uh maybe I'm
a glutton for punishment. Maybe I'm a
massochist but uh I'm still I'm still
going to be praying, you know, pray
actually like praying for him and hoping
that he comes around. So sucks. [__]
sucks. Yeah. Well, I think the bigger
thing to me is that like unfortunately
you you could say all this and you're
like, "Yeah, I totally agree with you.
He's actually reallyed up and he is like
really with you guys in a totally unfair
way." And then it's like, "But I am
going to approach him about canvasing."
It's like it's like a million voter
contacts or whatever it was. I'm like
1.6 million voter contacts. It's like
1.6 million voter contacts. Uh, how many
voter contacts do you think the
equivalent is for people remembering
Destiny calling for that for uh that
firefighter or laughing at that
firefighter getting killed? Do you think
that counts as like negative,000?
50,000 50,000 votes per death threat.
That's my ratio. Well, I was I was
saying more the Republican thing cuz for
me it's like it's not even remotely
solved that Destiny is like a positive
for the Democrat party even with the the
canvasing. Like that is not something
that people know at all based on how
inflammatory he is, how much of a piece
of he is, right? How hatable he is to
everybody. Uh, everybody who's who
doesn't hate the exact he Oh, well, I I
hope he I hope he's not, you know, it's
we didn't get 1.6 million votes, right?
It's 1.6 million voter contacts. But but
let's just say I I hope that uh Steven
isn't so politically repulsive that
he's, you know,
he's he's a negative past 1.6
million vote contacts. That'd be quite a
lot of damage. Uh I'm not saying it's
not possible. I'm just saying I I hope I
hope that's not the case. The uh Yeah.
So, hold on. Let me let me share
something with you, though, just because
I feel like you're smart enough to
appreciate it. So, the what's happening
right now is alter alternative media. Uh
politicians are trying to figure out how
to maybe not control, but control
alternative media and turn it into a
tool. that's what they're trying to
figure out. And so there's a lot of
people who have already done this
successfully. The problem is that
they're some of the biggest pieces of on
the internet. And so the question is how
do you get people who I don't know
actually care about things like actually
care about communities, actually care
about the welfare of the United States,
actually care about, I don't know,
principled things. Um how how do you
take the energy and passion that's in
alternative media and turn it into
something real? And nobody's figured it
out yet. And so even if Stephen uh let's
say he's like a serial killer, right?
I'm not saying he is. Let's say he is.
And in one year or two years, uh we
were, you know, the Democrats choose to
canvas with him. They use him. They get
DG to do 1.6 million more voter turns
out turnouts. And then it's revealed
that he's like a serial killer, right?
Yeah. Well, there's still technically
you would kind of know before, right?
What's that? Because now you you know
already about the serial killer thing.
It would be we're we're raising this
serial killer up because he's going to
get us votes. We're giving this guy
power and a ton of a bigger audience,
huge way of victims, and then we're
going to him because we'll get votes.
Well, for the for the sake of my
hypothetical, I wouldn't know that he
was a serial killer until it was
revealed, right? Uh so so the point is
that like we're still going to learn
lessons of taking an alternative media
figure and then trying to translate that
into real world action even if that
person is a bad person or is later
revealed to be a bad person. And so this
is the frontier and who figures it out
first does matter. And right now uh some
of the worst people on the planet are
dominating the sphere. So I care about
it. I'm going to work on it. Uh, I I I
don't know what that means for Stephen
and I's future. I don't know if we're
friends. I don't know if we're
collaborators. I don't know what the we
are, but that that's uh that's where I'm
at. I just feel like you admitted that
this guy's like a fairly bad person who
hurts a lot of people and has shown no
indication that they'll stop hurting
people. And then you followed that up by
saying, "But I do want to raise his
profile. I do want to make him as big as
I possibly can because I think it's good
for votes. I will just be your pay."
Yeah, I I care I care more about votes
than I care about homemade leaks,
whatever the [__] Yes. Will PV be
contacting him? Okay. All right. Uh can
I ask you based on all of this, why
would Destiny be a better choice than
Hassan? I I have a very personal uh
personal take on this. Uh because I
can't believe that Hassan had like like
I can't believe the
normality with which progressives and
liberals talk about Hassan when I've
seen Hassan, you know, like jokingly but
then not jokingly say that America
deserved 911. When I've seen him, you
know, make excuses for Hezbollah. When
I've seen Shouldn't that Wait, what if
that gets votes though? What if that
were to get him getting office? Yeah.
Yeah. My my line is jihadist terrorism.
That that actually is one of the
non-negotiables. Does Okay. Why? Yeah. I
I can answer why. Sure. So, when I when
I was when I was 14, I saw 3,000 people
butchered on live television. The home
city in which Hold on. The home city in
which I was born, uh, the B in Boston
that was bombed by
jihadist 5-year-olds. What's that? You
think Do you think jihadists watch
Hassan in the modern day? I think that
he radicalizes young Americans to
sympathize with jihadists. And what if
what if that prevents fascism from
taking over America? Why? What's that?
Why is that? Hold on. Why is that a
problem? Do you think do you think most
of America even if even if Assan got
them got people to be sympathetic? Do
you think Do you think that like uh most
people would be like, "Oh, 911 was like
not a big deal or 911 too is going to be
fine." I I will just I'm not sure what
you're asking me. What would I like
pragmatic? Can you tell Connor that is
typically used as an insult? I won't.
But you smaller words in shorter
sentences. I'm just saying that like by
your logic if Hassan was significantly
more impactful than Destiny. It's just a
util argument, right? Then why how is
the negative util of him uh celebrating
like 20 guys getting kidnapped, right?
Which realistically celebrating 20 guys
getting kidnapped minimizing some and
what is it? Like I I think the the
kidnapping thing was disgusting to me,
but realistically it's not really like I
would probably actually have more
criticism for if he doxed a bunch of his
critics and then said, "I hope somebody
rids me of these people. I hope somebody
goes and these people." I actually would
probably have more criticism for that.
So I actually don't know how you could
say Hassan is worse than destiny. Uh
yeah, it it actually is just like a hard
line with jihadist terrorism. Um so but
but here here's the thing. So here's the
thing. Sorry.
Uh, this is one of those things that's
so repulsive that I really wish that
there was like a a sensible rightwing.
It actually sucks that there isn't. But
I think I have to already before the
midterms, I have to make my piece
already with the fact that people view
Hassan differently than I do. And I
can't personally swallow the bitter pill
that would be like working with Hassan.
But there are people that I work with
who might work with us on like he's
already he's already talked to uh who is
it? AOC. He's already talked to Bernie.
I think he's already showed up to like
Bernie rallies. I think that uh there's
people who were in the I went to DC and
I went to a meeting. Um I think I and
someone else at the meeting were
forwarding the fact that sympathizing
with jihadist terrorism was probably a
hard line that we shouldn't cross. And I
think there were some people who thought
h you know maybe may maybe
Hassan's social relevance is more
important than a little bit of jihadist
sympathy. So there were people
definitely thinking like you were
thinking. I just can't think that way.
Okay. Yeah. I just I literally like it
seems like Hassan's the bigger platform
and he does less personally disgusting
things like to to the people around him.
like Hassan. Hassan maybe the worst I've
ever seen Hassan act to like somebody
he's like friends with is maybe to Ethan
which like that is pretty bad but like
he wasn't posting up Ethan's address and
saying like actually Ethan deserves to
die. Yeah. To to me Hassan though is uh
he's political rat poison because he's
just to me he's the inverse of MAGA.
He's everything that I fought against
for I don't know a half decade before
MAGA became relevant. So, so to me, to
me it's kind of like, well, shouldn't
you support anti-MAGA in order to defeat
MAGA? And it's like, you know, should I
drink rat poison in order to defeat my
cancer? There might actually be an
argument for rat poison defeating
cancer, but you know, I might still be
dead. But you understand, you're just
reskinning your argument you made in
favor of, well, if he saves two
children, you can rape one. Like, this
is just a
res I guess I'm a I'm a rule
utilitarian. Jihadist terrorism is worse
than [__] kids. No, Jesse didn't [__]
kids, right? He leaked homemade pine.
No, but you said you couldn't support
somebody who who elevates or supports or
has sympathized with jihadist
terrorists, but you could accept
somebody who raped one kid for every two
he saves. Okay, that was absolutely us
being hyperbolic on WOW or whatever
whatever's podcast and they they were
saying like oh yeah so that was
absolutely hyperbole where hyperbole was
where was like would you let Jimmy
Savile one kid if it saved 50,000 kids
from cancer and it's like yeah I'm going
to bite the bullet because this is a
like a raw hypothetical like yeah but
didn't you bring the bullet down you
bring the number down molest what's Uh I
thought you brought the number down to
like 10 10 kids saved to one. Well,
wait. Like uh what? Uh and bear in mind
we're being hyperbolic. God, we always
have to do the It's a joke. Yeah. Sorry.
Uh I do know you're trying to get your I
I understand that if you ever want to be
a safe word if you ever want to come on
again. Yeah. Now I have to explain that
like you know a child who get like or
whatever you know that they're still
alive so it's not as bad as jihadist
terrorism. Like I have to explain like
the differences between the two. Like
no, I think it's sufficient to say that
like that we all have to do a calculus
between the evils that we will tolerate
in the world in order to prevent
additional evils. We all have to make
that calculation.
And uh I I don't I don't think I've
settled on how allegedly evil Steven is
and how much uh I shouldn't be around
him because he's unrepentant. I I I
don't think I've decided that yet. Yeah.
I I mean I'm not like pushing you in a
direction. I'm mo mostly just working
off of the principles you stated, right?
That you needed contrition. You needed
um you you said you would always
distance yourself on, right? I'm just
gonna tell you I I've given I've given
up on contrition. I don't think he's
capable of it. Yeah, sure. It's like
it's like asking a a dog to ride a
unicycle. It's only going to happen
every so often. All right. Okay. Yeah.
I'm trying to think. I might I'll check
my document really quick. Um did you
want to take Some people asked to call
in. Did you want to take any callins
from people? Not really. It's kind of
late and I got [__] to do. But all
right. Um, you know, just uh for the
people who want to call in, just DM me
on Twitter, Discord, and if you're not a
then maybe I'll talk to you. I will say
that specifically. And so if it was,
would you make any exceptions or you
Yeah. Okay. No, no offense, but I don't
want to talk about the Jimmy Savile
ratio to kids to preventing cancer
analogy again. Okay. Uh, let's see here.
Um, I I wrote down like a couple things.
One was just Destiny consistently
muddies the water on what action he's
responding to hide the fact responding
to to hide the fact that he is not
directing his anger into the right place
whatsoever. That's just like when he
says there's lots of people on Jay Doc's
discord who do this he he never is
specific and then if he is specific it's
like not something that ties to me
except in the one case of Kelly Jean
where then if you're arguing about broad
character the discord where everybody
pushes back and I'm pushing back and
people have said oh it's good that you
push back like I feel like that's not
the same but yeah in in order for me to
take that seriously uh the Kelly Jean
Association or whatever then he wouldn't
have to disavow his 2022 content but he
would need to say going forward forward,
why he's not doing it, and how he
recognizes it's bad. So, just as an
example, uh I think I think a billion
orbiters came to him in 2022 and they
said, "Listen, like Lav's entertaining,
but she's terrible for XYZ ABC reason
and she's actually kind of like
destroying the social network." And then
people said the same thing about Max and
uh Destiny said, "I don't care. It's
fire content. Who gives a right?" And so
if if he's going to if he's going to
criticize you for having Kelly Jean on
for saying wild then he needs to say
basically well since 2022 I realize that
I hurt a lot of people despite producing
fire content and therefore I think I
have a moral responsibility in who I
platform. That way I don't hurt
additional people. Now, the problem with
that is it's hard to say that while
you're also saying these people should
be doxed and so but he would have to say
that in order for me to care about that
criticism. Okay. All right. Sorry. Did
you have another bullet point? Uh I
actually do need to check my document
one more time. That was at the very
bottom, but I think there was some stuff
we missed in the middle. Um I think we
we broadly hit all of it, I would say.
Um yeah, I don't need to like I
understand that you can change. I don't
need to sit here and like scream that
you're a hypocrite. And I I feel like I
didn't do that before. I feel like most
of my stuff before was um arguing on
points. I don't think I I think I
broadly most of the time it wasn't until
he started like uh threatening docs and
stuff that I was like oh I stopped
saying well if you watch him like I
don't care if you just think he's funny
and a bad person like I don't really
care. That's your prerogative. And now
that he's like you know doing the doxing
and threatening to saying like you
should please people. Now I'm like, "Oh,
actually watching him might actually be
a bad like a moral bad. It might
actually be prop into the world." Well,
in this this is the may maybe I've just
become like numb to Twitch and YouTube
politics over the past several years.
That's probably a that that might be a
problem. The I think it is a viol like a
a very strong violation of YouTube
creator norms and etiquette. So just as
an example, I debated Mike from PA. I
think you know like two or three years
ago. I think I called him a piece of
[__] [__] dumbass, whatever. But we
left it out on the field, right? Like
like we we had our debate. We disliked
each other viciously. We called each
other bad names. And then we left. And
there was no efforts on my part or
anybody that I'm associated with to find
his personal information in order to
make his life miserable. And as far as I
know, there was no effort on his part in
order to come after me. Even though
we're actually ideological enemies. if
he had a gun and I had a gun and we were
fighting for the future of the country,
we might actually legitimately like
smoke each other, right? So, but the
thing is we left it out on the field
because it's better to have these
conversations here than it is to try to
ruin each other's personal lives. And so
the fact that Stephen is openly saying,
"Yes, I want Queenman's personal life.
Yes, I want JTO's personal life ruined,
uh, or harassed, uh, he needs to have a
goddamn fantastic justification for
that, or else he's violating probably
one of the biggest social norms in the
Twitch and YouTube political space." And
I I probably should be more alarmed. I I
think I think my I think my brain is
just like numb and dead at this point.
Well, I also like I understand and
that's why I've tried to be a little
more calm in this conversation because
like this was broadly before this I
think most of the time when I had
arguments with people at least on my
platform I try to be like understanding.
I I know that um people will disagree
with you if they think you're an
[__] right? Even if they think even
if they know you're right, they'll
disagree with you, right? So, if I was
sitting here like screaming that you're
like a horrible hypocrite, you won't
disavow this guy, I think you'd broadly
not be as receptive. So, I'm just trying
to be a little more calm and cool about
it. Um so, I hope that I'll put it under
consideration. If anything, I think you
uh you gave me more things that I have
to think about now, which is a pain in
the ass, but I guess it's good for you.
Yeah. All right, cool. Well, thanks for
coming on. I heard your I obviously
watching I heard your Warhammer channel
hit 100K so you get your little plaque
and stuff. That's pretty cool. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. So, uh ju just just sharing
even though we were talking about uh
kids in order to save them with cancer.
Uh good news on my front. So, uh I did
break 100k on the Warhammer channel. I
did get my silver play button. It does
bring in a little bit of money. Uh also,
I started streaming full-time. Uh so,
I'm doing that in two locations. Uh one
of them is my Counterpoints political
channel. There I'll be live from noon to
5:00 on Tuesday. And then Monday through
Friday, all the other days, I'm live on
the Valor Media Network. Uh, and
basically it's
uh, just being transparent, it's it's
there's not really like a political
direction to it. It's just broadly anti-
athoritarian uh,
anti-MAGA. And then, uh, it's like first
responders, veterans, uh, cops, Navy
Seals, all that kind of stuff. They're
all starting a bunch of different
podcasts and shows on it in order to try
to be like more positive in the world
and then uh Valor is allowing me to
stream uh 20 hours a week on their
channel and talk smack about you know
alternative media figures. Okay. Is this
um you might not be able to answer. Is
this a part of like your political
project? Like you're getting paid by
like uh some pack money, some political
Yeah. Uh believe it or not, it's
actually an offshoot of Midas. Okay.
mightest touch. So, I've heard of those
guys. They got they, you know, one or
200 thousand subs, I think, or one or
two million, something like that. I
think they I think they have a few
million. I think they're like the most
popular channel on YouTube right now.
So, yeah, they're Yeah. So, it's an it's
an offshoot of Midas Touch. Uh they're
they're giving me a shot. I got six
months to uh build something. Uh and
then if it's successful and the channels
pop in and we got money and we got
revenue and we're doing great, then
that'll be my job going forward. And
then if 6 months uh it doesn't work,
then I'll be reporting back to the wage
cage. So, we'll we'll we'll see. But say
say a prayer for me. Yeah. No, I mean uh
yeah, I hope I hope this goes well for
you. Hope the Warhammer stuff continues
to go well. I know I had fun the one
night Yumi and Really watched uh A
Stardies. Good. Yeah, it was good stuff.
It's very fun. It was better with you
there though to explain everything that
was going on. So, well, if uh if we ever
get away from obviously like in drama,
if it bleeds, it leads. But if uh if we
ever get away from uh drama and we need
to revisit Warhammer, I'll be happy to
be your Warhammer Sherpa. Okay. Yeah.
Thank you. All right. Well, sounds good.
Yeah. I hope I can have you on again if
you want to talk. I'm covering I think
more politics now. Um we'll see
specifically. It's just it seems to be
just seems to be the easier way to go
about um filling time when there's not
big drama going on. Reed. What do you
mean ask about? Yeah. Also, I might be
going into some true crime or legal
stuff. I think the I think the legal
stuff is like uh trying to do a stickick
in like law tube as somebody without a
law degree. I think that would be very
funny. Look, I'll I'll predict these
cases better than these guys with chat
GPT. I think would broadly be the idea.
I don't know if it would work, but Well,
and that that's one of the things that I
found very interesting. And so I would,
you know, obviously talking about Sneo,
Andrew Tate, Vosch, uh, Benny Johnson,
Noah Samson, all those people. Um, on
stream, you're, you know, your numbers
can bump up when you're, and by the way,
their their release schedule is crazy
and their thumbnails are crazy. I'll
I'll be talking to them about it. Don't
worry about it. But the, but the point
is that, uh, talking politics and
politics drama obviously can bump your
numbers a little bit. But what's cool
about Valor is since it's like
veterancoded,
um, I started talking about like a law
enforcement shooting and I started
talking about military tech that was
coming out and my my numbers went up
when I moved away from the drama and I
was like, "Oo, that's that's cool." So,
so I'll still be talking about politics
and drama and alternative media
personalities, but I'll also be talking
about police shootings and uh you know,
crime issues and body cameras and
military technology. Okay. Yeah, sounds
good. I hope I hope it goes well. I
don't know. I have like no idea. By the
way, the thumbnails look pretty on meta
to me. The arrows are like on meta. The
arrow is just the meta. Okay. You don't
make a thumbnail without an arrow right
now. That arrow has to be pointing at
somebody. Okay. Yeah. My Okay. my I I'll
just say my type in uh go to Midas real
quick though. I was just going to I was
just going to show you the arrow on your
latest video. Just look, it's got an
arrow. Look, it's got an The arrow
arrows are meta. Okay, I'm trying to get
this guy under control. He's out of this
He's out of control. Okay, but I don't I
don't own the channel. I can't actually
officially I I can't even DMCA people on
YouTube, okay? They could just take all
my content. There's nothing I can do
about it. We go to Midas real quick. Oh,
Midas. M. Oh, yeah. The yellow arrows on
Midas. Yeah, I know. I know about these.
Well, so all I was going to say is I if
I had to look at Luke Beasley, Adam
Mockler, Midas Touch, uh even Destiny to
an extent Josiah Josiah, this is this
seems like the best thing is your
subject large then large text with a
brief summary and then a not necessarily
hyperbolic but an
exclamatory or questioning sentence.
as a title. That seems to be what
actually ras it in. And so if I was
making a recommendation to anybody who's
trying to make it big in like political
commentary, uh this seems to be the what
what all the successful people are
doing. Whereas if you have busy text and
too many characters, it's it's too busy.
People don't click on it as much. So I
used to talk with August um Destiny's
editor and he was the one who pointed
this trend out to me. And the basic idea
is once like really big channels are
doing this and then some smaller
channels start to build up audience
based on doing it. It's like everybody
can chameleon in and sort of draft after
the after the audience like draft uh
behind that big channel and catch a
bunch of their audience who will be like
oh that's a that's this video and then
it won't be that video but it's the
video they wanted to watch cuz they
clicked on it right and then they'll sit
there and they'll watch. And that's like
broadly I think how Josiah I mean I will
say Josiah is incredibly informed. He
puts a ton of work into his videos and
but like aside from that, this is one of
the ways he could draft off of these
bigger channels. Ended up uh yeah,
actually you were going to type in
counterpoints 40k. Type in counterpoints
40k real quick. Points 40k. So click on
that. Nobody cares about black talon,
which is the last three uh anywhere near
as much. But like raptors, hammer and
bolter, a stardis 2. Um I'm trying to
think of what else. Uh the secret level
was going to be big no matter what. I
could have the thumbnail ever. But but
if you notice the way that we're doing
thumbs, sometimes I would take battle
scenes and I would make the battle
scenes the thumbs, but to be honest,
they didn't perform as well as a
definitive character. Big subject. Yeah.
Big subject. Yeah. Yeah. So, so the
reason why I always have like a face or
a mask or a face and a gun or something
like that um is because it seems like
people that that is the best way to get
somebody's time and attention is to have
a declarative uh a declarative title uh
mixed with an identifiable subject. And
if you don't have an identifiable
subject, if you have too many words on
it, um it's just too busy and people
don't click on it as much. Yep. Yep.
Yeah. It's like glancing you aspiring
creators out there. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Cool. All
right. Anything else you wanted to bring
up or No, that's it. Um if if you guys
uh it's not going to it'll be news then
it'll be probably uh breaking down some
alternative media personality and then
it'll be military tech and that kind of
stuff. But if you guys are uh whoever's
watching, if you need something to watch
um from noon to 5 EST, Monday through
Friday, come check me out on Valor Media
and or just counterpoints my political
channel and I'll see you there. Cool.
All right. Thanks for coming on. Have a
good one. Talk to you later. Appreciate
you. You too. Good night. Bye. Good
night. Beep. I think Queen might have
wanted to hop on here after this convo.
Back into the open channel. Do people
want to talk? Want to chat? Say some
stuff. Whoa, that was really fast. Fat
guy, am I right? Right after I was like,
"Oh, hey, I'm trying to be nice to What
a piece of What a piece of that guy." I
like that much. Yeah. I don't know. That
That went decently. I don't know. I
Yeah, it was into a blood lust at the
end when I started hearing him say, "How
terrorism is my red line?" I'm like,
"Bro, come on. The the American 911
thing is like not that bad really. It's
like fine. It's just a point about
blowback. You're actually you are gay if
you get upset about that sort of thing.
You are just being a yancoid like a
mama. I I thought about going into that
like do you do you think about why
Hassan says that when it's like the
point about you know western imperialism
up these countries and them having like
a blood debt against the US. Maybe if
people uh listen to that quote a bit
closer. Maybe uh you know they would
have more criticism for Israel right now
on the on the merits of you know just
their own interests. Interesting how he
brings up 9/11 and Hassan talking about
9/11 for um a reason we won't associate
with him. But but what about uh what
about Pearl Harbor? He's still like, you
know, we'll collaborate with uh what's
his face as he's like going to Japan?
What about the USS Liberty? But he's
still associated with Destiny while he's
defending Israel. What? What? What is
the USS Liberty? I've never heard of
this before. Queen, you heard of the USS
Liberty before? No. This is some strange
insane. So like this is only I feel like
this or something like far right. No no
no no no liberty. The stickers guy
sounds antis actually. It was an
accident but it was still immoral. Okay.
People died. It was an accident. It was
an accident. It was an accident. They
accidentally drove up to this boat and
then strafed all of the survivors very
accidentally. I don't actually think
that happened. It's just like a random
video. I can't remember where we saw
that. Maybe it's on I can't remember
where we watched. Somebody said that in
a video recently. We've been watching
some weird [__] Um, yeah. Did you have
any thoughts on that that convo? How it
was going? How it went? Dude, that was
uh because I Yes, because I just
finished watching the conversation he
had with Destiny the uh the other day.
He's not changed his position at all. At
all. Um, and yeah, still getting like
talking points from Destiny. Um, it's
like, yeah, I mean I I would he sat
there, he went through the message and
he said that he thought Destiny was
wrong. So he he did he said Destiny was
wrong, but he like has he changed his
association with him like at all. Um, to
be determined and I to in the debate he
had with Destiny I mean he didn't even
really challenge him on it at all like
pointing to somebody's like public only
fans. I don't know. It's just everything
he says is so hyperbolic. The way he
describes his own stuff is like, you
know, um like the most minimalist like
interpretation you could possibly give
while being like technically maybe like
factually correct. And the way he talks
about what everyone else is doing is uh
the most hyperbolic stuff. It's like
completely dishonest. Yeah. I think it
was just generally like not when I
pointed out the whole Shondaanda Black
thing gave me that point. Um just like
like I remember everybody around Destiny
retweeting. I made like some tweets
about that and I could go look. I could
actually probably just go find it on my
account and see like all the people who
retweeted it and just look at the ones
that are like silent now and like oh
well what can you do? He's he's calling
for people's deaths. What can you do?
Right stickers. Did you actually watch
that the the whole conversation you had
with Destiny? Even the very very end.
Even the very very end.
Dude, somebody told me about your um
your DM to Connor uh when I first
started watching it. Trolling me. I was
with him. I literally didn't expect him
to do it. I was just I was just [__] it.
Cuz he was annoying me that he wasn't
arguing back at all. So I was just like,
"Well, you gay if you don't do this
thing." Oh, okay. So you're gay then.
That's what I said to him in DMs like
you're gay if you don't do this. Like
five, oh, so you're gay then. Like
literally stop watching and then yeah, I
heard about this is a reminder, you
know, if you ever want Connor to say
something to Destiny live while he's in
a debate with him, just call him gay.
Just call him gay. a real do it out of
shame. Oh my god. And and Destiny didn't
even deny it, which is like, oh my god.
No, he justified both. He He justified
it twice. He justified it once by
himself and he justified it when Connor
was on stream. He's like, no, this is
why I did that. Why I called for their
death. Oh yeah, definitely. And then it
was like a non-answer. What's that?
Because my signals, but yeah. Oh, sorry.
Sorry. I was just looking at this tweet
had 6.6 million views and 2.2K likes. me
being like, "Hey, it's really gay that
this Shondaanda black guy is calling for
violence against Destiny." Apparently, a
lot of people cared. See, Icarus Bath
was mad about it. You guys can keep
talking, but I'm going to keep
scrolling. Sorry, I was paying attention
to Twitter. My bad. No, no, no, it's
right. Oh, look. Yeah, look, he is
there. He is there saying it's bad. What
do you want me to say?
That's basically that that was like my
reasoning for feeling like a I'm like I
feel like a for saying this was bad. And
then all of the people who retweeted it,
Ro, they don't give a They're just like,
"Yeah, whatever. You deserved it." Okay.
Kelly Jean talked about his
girlfriend's, but you deserve to be
doxed and killed now. Oh, look. It's
August. Also, somebody who's like,
"Yeah, you probably just deserve to be
killed and doxed." But whatever. That's
fine. Well, I don't I don't think August
thinks that. I don't think August thinks
that. Uh, okay. disturbing things I'm
hearing about this app as well. Just a
quick reminder, PSA, don't push when you
shoot it. You know, more fiber. Yeah.
Okay. Okay. Oh, look. Willy Mack was
really Willy Mack wanted to amplify this
one, too. Crazy. Oh my god, that's
really funny, actually. And then fast
forward, what is it? Less than a year.
And he's like, actually, would these
guys get death threats? It's like I just
think about how annoying they are
actually. Amazing. Maybe, hold on,
though. But maybe Willy Mack's video
will be like, "Destiny's actually
insane. Look at how insane he's gone."
Did you see that? Um, Tommy C put out a
30-minute video about the the ye stuff.
What ye stuff? The Willy Mack and us.
Dang. Oh, no. But I'm
guessing basically 13 minutes. Yeah.
Yeah, it's basically 13 minutes of just
Well, actually, I I hate you. So, it's
basically getting death threats. That's
like the whole 13 minutes. It's like,
okay, fair enough. But it's not
particularly compelling. I can't be
real. Yeah. I just I as we go through
time, I'm just more and more
blackpilled. Like literally, listen,
it's some people here. This guy, if this
guy said that we're we're like we're
we're losers, so it's okay to kill us. I
I'd be like, "Okay, you're consistent.
You thought it was bass when Shawn Black
did it. You think it's bass when when uh
when Destiny does it? That's
consistent." I don't care when Shauna
Black did it. I don't care when Destiny
does it. I think it's gay as a
hypocrisy, to be honest. So, just say
you don't care. I never cared. It was
kind of funny actually to be honest.
Wait. Um, what did he say? He said this
what happens when you every slave owner.
Was that it? Uh, this what happens when
you he said somebody would destiny and
like then socialism would prosper in
America. Slave owner thing. Just go and
just says the n word. Okay. Which is not
a surprise.
Every slave owner after slavery they
have kids and their kids become destiny.
Yeah, it was like the same string. That
part that part was funny. That part was
funny. That that they're so gay. That
part was funny. Did Connor address
Destiny leaking the name of Lauren
Southern's kid to a Discord holder? Uh,
listen, she's just a worker. Don't call
her Discord. Discord kitten, please use
the proper name. Uh, no, but I talked
about it in DMs. I can't remember. He
didn't really He was like, "Oh, that's
what happens when I He kind of committed
in that direction. He was like, I guess
shouldn't shouldn't share things with
Destiny. What can you do?" Um, let's see
here. What did you think about Destiny?
Uh, sorry about Connor referring to the
whole Dachshun thing as a as a breach of
etiquette, like a kind of a, you know,
kind of a a social faux part. It's a
breach of etiquette. Oh, I mean, he
started going back to like, no, it's
actually really bad. No, it's actually
really bad. As I continue to sort of
explain sort of like Destiny's standard
for being allowed to dox and send death
threats towards people or say you want
people to kill them was like essentially
nothing. no proof, no nothing. And if
you like accept that standard, then what
would prevent it from coming at you? Uh
I also asked him like basically like
what would you do if this guy flipped on
you too? Like basic it seems like it's
just people who like turned against him
and the wicked by asking that question
that that I sent him. He's literally
already created the grounds for Destiny
to flip on at any time. Destiny could
literally start going down in full force
and he it's already justified like he
just etiquette to downplay the breach. I
don't know. I don't get too hung up on
people's words. Like I But that's just
me. I don't know. Maybe I'm just I just
don't care when people use the etiquette
or when ye tweeted like, "Oh, this is a
spicy thing." Just doesn't bother me. I
guess it it bothers some people. I never
It's It depends. Maybe if it's like
against me, I don't care. I I do notice
it when it's against other people, I
guess. So, sorry answering a chat
message there. Yeah, he broadly just
gave Oh, and Erdite, too. And it's like
realistically, how do I know that you
and Erdite aren't supporting him because
you guys just don't want to get I don't
know. I like at some point I don't know
like are are the people even supporting
him just like terrified of this guy or
maybe not maybe in denial about being
terrified of the guy, right? Like well I
guess I made my bed. Guess I made my
bed. Guess I have to stay here now. I I
think the thing I've I've said I think a
couple of times is like Connor's trying
to like start streaming regularly. He's
kind of starting to rely on this for
like a job. Um a lot of the other people
he has like connects with don't really
like him. Uh especially after like the
PV stuff, the association with Brianna
Woo. Now, the Destiny stuff, he could
try and move away from Destiny, but he's
never gonna like explicitly uh like
condemn him. And he he probably needs
that kind of like connect for growth.
Like he's coming on like my live stream
with like 80 viewers and trying to like
say, "By the way, by the way, I'm going
to be streaming soon. By the way, by the
way, I'm going to be, you know, this
time to this time I'm going to be
streaming." He'll go on any he'll go on
anyone's stream anyway. So, he Yeah. And
he literally said on my stream, he was
like, "Yeah, I just because people were
open with me, like even bigger creators
like Destiny and Bosch that like I try
to extend that to everybody even though
like I'm like he he wasn't even trying
to say he was bigger than me. He was
just like I just try to make sure if
people ask me for a combo and I have
time, I do it. Yeah. Yeah. Like I'd say
that's probably No. No. Yeah. I don't
know if it's mostly about growth and he
will shut him shut himself out, but I
think that's usually he probably just
assumes he's got that like right by
hopping on your stream for free, right?
No, that's fair. That is fair. No, I'm
not bemmoning him for that at all. I was
just think I was just saying that um I
think he's probably keeping the the
Destiny connect for um
kind of growth or viewership or you know
to get more follows and stuff. Yeah. Um
and like I I just think if I had to
guess I would think that probably a lot
of this is more about Arrodite than it
is Destiny to be honest him being
friends with Ardite. I think Erodite has
some ultra negative opinions of me and
Queen. Um I don't think she's advocating
for this by the way. I'm saying that
like probably a lot of Destiny's actions
are based on Erdite feeling really bad
about getting criticized and like um
people being unhinged towards her and
probably a lot of Connor's actions are
also based on that. I think they just
have like a fairly warped perception
based on them believing Erdite's like a
a victim. I don't know. That's that's my
mind readad of the situation. Maybe
that's totally unfair, but I think
that's probably like he's probably
sticking by Destiny because he wants to
stick by Aerudite and that's to to be
honest that's like that seems to be more
what it is. I don't know if he really
they considered not encouraging their
mentally disabled friend to do politics.
That seems cruel to me. That's I I I
would never argue that Erd like deserves
it, right? But um like at least not uh
like I think she has been I think she's
had PII revealed and I I don't know if
she's been swatted, but it wouldn't
shock me. Like I think like she's
probably in the same situation that
Queen and I are in terms of feeling like
under threat. And maybe you could try to
say, "Well, by watching her content and
reacting to it and being like rude,
you're continuing that, but then I don't
know how you justify any of the content
in this entire space for the past 5
years." Yeah. Conor I think Connor would
say that's just the game, right? He he
would probably say my coverage is the
game. Yeah. Well, I think so. Like you
put out public messaging and you put up
public statements. I think you should
just be able to mostly like I I don't
I've never gotten mad about people
reacting to my except that one time
Nicholas reacted to it and then refused
to talk to me. That was annoying as
actually he agreed to talk to me and
you're not mad about the reaction.
You're mad about my mate. Yeah. Although
I do I I remember when Nicholas used to
come in the Discord and hang out. Never
again. I guess we had to be divas. Oh,
because because you were a diva. Not me.
You You were a diva. I I I Yeah, I don't
even I By the way, I also like let the
whole Willie Mac thing go. He was like
seething on Twitter for like two weeks
after that and he was like talking [__]
about me, random replies. I was just
like, "You know what? I won't I won't
say anything." I think I made a comment
in spicy chat that one guy got uh angry
about, but that was it. It was really
over the Willie Mac stuff. Yep. I I
didn't think he got himself that that
involved in um in the in the Willy Mack
conversation at the time. Uh no, he got
fairly involved, but I think it was
mostly just protecting a friend. You
deserted the forever war against Willie.
No, I said I said if there was going to
be a war, I'd fight, but I was just like
I just wanted it to die because I wanted
to focus on covering some Destiny stuff,
you know, as that developed. By the way,
you guys, um, feel free to talk or jump
in whenever you want. I'm like I had
like two hours of sleep. So, I I did not
my brain my brain worked for about an
hour and a half talking to Connor and
now it's it's over. Holy moly. Um, we
have a bigger fish to cook. Well, we did
back then. Now it's like now I'd much
rather talk to Willie about stuff. I'd
tell Willie to hop on the stream, too.
Maybe Willie would hop on the stream and
just like squash the beef. Here, you
know what? I'm I'm gonna send Willie a
message right now. I get the feeling
that Willy's uh stream uh stream guest
appearances might be over for a little
while. I'm not sure. Hey, you never
know. I messaged him. Any chance he'd
want to hop on stream and squash the
beef? Hey, I messaged him. What do you
mean by squash the beef? What? You wanna
You want to argue? Oh, you just said I'm
so annoying that he doesn't care that
I'm getting death threats. So, I mean,
like, there must be some beef there. No.
Wow. I think I think this is another
aspect of um what do you call it? I
think this is an whole play this right
now. Oh god, did I what did I say into a
thing and Queen's on one side. I'm on
Queen's side. Okay, that guy I'm on his
side. So I don't need anything. If you
guys can't squash that yourselves, I
will eventually once we're past this be
on whatever side he's on. Okay, I'm just
saying it. Just letting you know. Yeah,
that's um that that was my position was
like, hey, if you guys are like going to
go after Queen or something, I will
absolutely participate, but if it just
dies down, that's better. Yeah. Uh, I I
would just say like whatever is leading
to you like having the hatred going on.
Uh, if he wants to squash that beef